Yeah,
dude,
you're fucking Instagram things that you're doing these Hong Dynasty things.
What are you doing?
That shit is hilarious.
You and Bobby Lee and these 15 second clips,
I'm hooked.
I don't know what you're doing but I'm laughing my dick off.
Um,
I mean first of all,
people always like to like it's publicly known that I'm wealthy because of the
New York Times and all this shit that came out,
the Facebook stuff.
So people always like whenever I do anything to preface it with,
well,
if I was rich or if I had your fuck you money or if you know,
and I go this shit.
Most of everything I do cost little or nothing like the Han Dynasty is okay,
so Instagram comes out and what?
Vine is like seven seconds,
right?
I don't have vine,
but vine is seven seconds.
Instagram's 15 seconds.
We're old guys.
When I go hang out with my nephews and stuff and they were like teenagers,
like they won't even watch a one minute youtube clip.
It's like,
if it doesn't get their attention,
they're like,
or they'll just,
they'll watch it with the,
the bar.
Just fast forward,
fast forward and,
you know,
so I said,
let's just fuck around.
We filmed this thing on our iPhone and uh,
it's just,
you know,
Bob,
Bobby Lee's actually an actor or,
you know what,
before we get started,
let me just say,
I was on Joe show last time and it ended with me saying it was a dumb idea,
but I was like,
I'm,
I'm extremely unhealthy.
I'm out of shape.
I had mercury poisoning,
high blood pressure,
high cholesterol,
all that shit.
I just got diabetes and I said,
I'm going to get diabetes or whatever.
I mean,
everyone's,
everyone's going to have it soon.
But,
uh,
I said,
I'm going to,
what did I say?
I was gonna spend a year to get trained and I want to have like a UFC fight or
some shit like that.
And you were explaining to me how Bellmont was Bobby Lee's brother,
Steve Lee,
who's 40 years old,
who's one of those guys.
He's,
he's like a thousand times funnier than Bobby without trying like Bobby's like a
professional comedian.
Steve just,
he's just a funny and crazy guy.
He's one of the,
he's got a sort of Al Bundy thing where he's 40,
and he talks about how he could have been state champions just if you just did
this one arm bar or something.
And he works at or used to work at this place,
fat cells in Hollywood,
part time as a sandwich guy.
And I hired him to be on my show full time and,
and he started slacking.
It was what I thought would happen.
And I said,
all right,
you and me are going to go into this room and we're going to Russell and you're
basically wrestling for your job.
You're,
you're doing wrestling and I'm doing judo and I outweigh him by 60 pounds.
He's like a little tiny Asian guy,
right?
And I'm like,
yeah,
he used to do judo and um,
my friend was like,
dude,
don't underestimate him cause you know,
he,
he was almost state champ.
I'm like,
that was like over 20 years ago.
He's like,
but yeah,
those little wrestling guys,
you know,
um,
you can't fuck with them.
And then his brother was the referee,
so says Dave,
my brother,
you know,
he's like very relaxed and lazy about things until you challenge his pussy or
money.
So Steve,
you know,
Steve's on the Han Dynasty.
He's like a fucking,
you know,
he's a crazy guy.
He's always good natured.
He's always funny when I told him like,
if you don't win this,
you're going back to fat cells.
And the job he has for me right now,
it's like,
they're like,
what do you need to hire Steve Leaf?
Or what did he do?
I'm like,
I literally send them all over the world to fuck as many horses as possible.
Like that's his job.
That's his job right now.
Having sex with prostitutes.
Yeah.
I send him,
I send him like him,
basically him and uh,
this guy bill poon,
he's 53 years old.
I sent them to Macau there,
the Macau brothers now and bill bill on his normal job when he's not on my show
is he drives hookers around.
He's the number one whore transporter in Los Angeles.
Um,
I think he put 290,000 miles on is a Prius.
And I said,
do the math and he has delivered 6,000 hookers to their John's.
Wow.
And I go,
that makes you the number one hort transporter.
Maybe there's a guy out there that's just fucking doing math and staying up all
night and just trying to break that record.
Well he hasn't,
he hasn't,
he has his arch enemy and everything.
It's like a whole nother gap.
Yeah,
there's another guy.
Um,
but he's like,
he's like a,
what's that movie?
The transporter.
He never tries to fuck the hookers.
He's serious about it.
He's got like baby wipes and condo.
He's like,
he's like,
he takes the job seriously.
He's not does any creepy shit.
So him,
him and Steve,
I go,
hey you guys,
you know,
everyone hears stories about like the sec underground sex world in Macau and
this,
why don't you go and investigate?
And by investigating,
I mean fuck all of them.
And so I send them to Macau.
We record the whole thing that's going to be called the Macau brothers.
And we're going to put that up on DVD,
AAC,
whatever.
But uh,
so go back to this wrestling match.
Okay.
So
w so mission thing or you,
whoever wins.
Well that's why I'm not a wrestler.
So Bobby's like Bobby used to wrestle too,
so he's like,
I'll be the referee and yeah,
whoever,
whoever gets the first person down submit whatever they win,
you know,
but what is whatever like is it to tap out?
Because if you get a Jujitsu guy down,
it doesn't mean Jack Shit.
Right.
That's when the game starts.
Right,
right,
right.
You know guys all about what you call he pawn slam a guy.
Yeah.
It was just a,
I guess whoever gets someone in a hold that they can't get out of her,
something undefined.
Undefined victories.
Yeah.
Cause there they're just no punching or kicking.
It wasn't.
Yeah.
And so yeah,
him working for me is not like sweeping the floor or whatever.
Him working for me is getting to fuck really hot chicks to great gig.
Yeah.
So essentially his face changes cause I'm like,
and I'm like,
ah,
I'm
probably still give him his job.
Even if,
and I go,
I'm just,
all I'm going to do is let them fuck.
He's like,
he's like,
you know,
half of my size,
I'm going to be size,
but like waste skinnier when I go,
I'll just let them fuck around and then I'll just flatten them when they'll
just,
it'll be,
it'll look funny,
you know,
in less than a minute.
He took me off.
I go,
if you don't win right now,
you fucker,
you're losing your job.
His fee.
He goes,
red zone,
his face.
And I go,
Oh fuck dude,
this guy.
And then he comes at me and he's small,
but then he just like grabbed my arm or something gets me down and I'm like,
oh,
whatever.
And then I can't get out of it.
And then he just puts all of his mind into this hole and I'm just sitting there
and I can't get out of it.
And I'm like,
you know,
I'm also curious.
She's just like,
I've never seen you look more like a pussy in your life.
And I was sitting there thinking,
fuck dude,
I remember I told Joe that I was going to do this shit.
Like people have that glamorous idea that they're going to go and have an MMA
fight.
I would never discourage anybody from being an MMA fighter.
I think you live and you die if you want to be a bull rider.
If you want to ride motocross,
if you want to drive Formula One,
race cars,
all those things are dangerous.
All those things are awesome.
You know,
live your life,
man.
I thought I did it.
I mean it's not,
I mean I,
I fought in taekwondo and I kickbox it's fucking stupid.
It's tainted.
I did it for free.
There was no money involved in it.
I couldn't,
I had no insurance.
I had no health insurance.
So I would never tell someone don't do anything dangerous,
but he can't.
I don't think you should dabble.
That's something like there's dudes that are doing it that I know that are like
trying to make him the UFC or have made it into the UFC that that's their
fucking whole life,
man.
They get up in the morning,
they're doing their strength and conditioning.
They're running,
they're drinking wheat grass juice in.
They're fucking taken all their amino acids.
Joe,
I'm not done babble.
I'm good.
They made UFC their life.
I'm gonna make,
I'm going to make a serious commitment to my diabetes.
I'm going to make that my life.
I'm going to eat doughnuts.
I'm going to fucking do you really have diabetes?
I just,
I was prediabetic for like the last four years and I like just cross over the
line.
I just crossed over and he's like,
dude,
with,
with lots of the complete nutritional diet change and lots of exercises,
like you can go back to not having diabetes,
but whatever.
He would rather not.
You'd rather just take insulin and just eat donuts.
I know.
It's horrible.
That's so bad.
Everyone's like,
well,
they say 50% of everyone that's being born in America today will have diabetes.
Why don't you do this and swore on the show,
okay,
you and I are talking and we're friends.
Why don't you hire someone?
So you got boatloads of cash.
Hire someone to concoct a diet for you to,
to feed.
You.
Hire someone that's a nutritionist that is going to concoct like really healthy
meals all day long,
really low sugar,
and you'll hear that shit within a few months.
I mean,
you just met him right now.
First of all,
credit credit's going to do it.
Well,
this is,
this is what happens when I made my money.
I naturally,
I just don't trust people.
So I made the room naturally before or I just always,
So I
just made the rookie mistake.
You've heard the expression before,
don't hire your friends and family.
And I hired all,
only my friends and family and I was like,
you know,
hey,
I don't know how to work a camera.
I don't care.
You're my cousin.
You have to,
you know,
I just wanted everyone around me to be someone I trusted.
And,
uh,
it just,
you don't get the level of work that,
you know,
like I work every night till seven,
eight in the morning still.
I don't have to,
but I do,
you know,
and you know,
without even,
cause th there's always in the back of their mind,
they're like,
Dave's not going to fire me.
Right?
Like he's my cousin or he's my best friend,
like right.
And then I was just sitting there going,
how come I do have all this money and I hired all these guys and I'm overpaying
the shit out of him.
And like I'm still at the office by myself,
you know.
So I fired everyone.
I only hired people that are not my friends and white and I said,
no more Asians.
I'm only on your hiring white people and man,
that's crazy racist.
Very racist.
Shins are very hard workers as long as you're not your family.
Um,
I dunno,
I just,
I just wanted to,
first of all,
yeah,
it's very racist and I was like,
okay,
because you want to,
I want to try something different.
I already wrote the yellow train and we get on a white shirt.
And uh,
so I hired,
I hired people that are not friends I'm friendly with,
but they're not my homeys.
And then,
and then there they were hired for specifically what their job was like.
If you're a trainer then that's what I,
you know,
I'm not like,
Hey,
I know you're not a trainer but just do it.
And,
uh,
I found out with this next phase of the experiment that I immediately like be
friended all of them.
Like now they're all my best friends and,
and even if I like critter,
you know,
I said,
listen,
I have diabetes.
I,
you know,
and he's also my body guard,
which everyone thinks is a joke,
which is,
which it is most of the time.
But you know,
weird shit happens once in a while.
And I said,
look,
I love eating.
I'm a friends with lots of shifts.
You know,
I go to a lot of restaurants,
you know I love,
I have a a piece of me that's like,
you remember just having no money and going to a restaurant or a nice restaurant
for the first time and just like having that snooty and I'm looking at Sushi
menu and going like,
what's,
what's MP like?
I didn't know cause I'd never been there.
And they're like,
that's market price sir.
And I'm like,
well how the fuck am I to,
okay,
so this a Toro,
what does that?
And they're like,
it's the fattest part of the tuna and it's $60 a piece.
You mean for the two pieces?
No,
no,
no.
For one piece.
And I'm like $120 for two tiny fucking pieces of fish,
but you know,
I didn't have any money.
I'm like,
I'm not going to get there.
And they're like,
yeah,
if you have to ask,
then you can't afford it.
And so now I have the money and I go in there.
Yeah,
motherfucker give me a hundred Toro.
What?
I'm like,
give me the whole fucking fish.
And then it's like,
oh two and it has the most amount of mercury and you know,
the doctor checks my blood and he's like,
you have so much mercury in your fucking blood,
you know exactly.
That really happened to you.
Yeah.
Like you were eating that much Sushi that you well I thought I thought it was
healthy and you know the,
the oceans are polluted the shit so polluted their full full of like radioactive
waste and all this shit.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I'm not eating hamburgers anymore in every meal costs $500.
I'm rich motherfucker.
And it's like moderation for everything.
Can't eat fish every day.
You know,
I was starting to get,
um,
was it?
God Damn it,
I forget the poisoning that I was getting from sardines.
Yes.
Sardines have tons of our snack.
Yeah,
I was getting arsenic.
Sardines have tons of that shit.
It was a small amount.
It's a heavy metal,
you know,
they're eating at the bottom of the ocean and he's just fucking garbage down.
And then once that shit gets in your blood,
it takes forever to get out.
You know,
it didn't take long.
I,
yeah,
I got rid of the arsenic in the short amount of time.
I just stopped eating sardines.
Oh,
I was hitting him every day.
Wow.
Yeah.
White trash.
I like sardines.
Sardines.
Well I guess I don't know about the arsenic,
but they said,
well I just,
because my hair started falling out and I couldn't,
you know,
I'm like,
I'm still relatively young,
but I just,
mercury was making your hair fall.
Well it said for mercury poisoning,
it's like memory loss and like,
it's like,
I,
I'm like,
I have the same memories.
My 70 year old father,
he's like,
well,
you know,
I'm like,
people will do the,
hey Dave,
you just told that story.
And I'm like,
really?
And I'm like fuck.
And it's like,
I know that like,
it's like when you know something but you're feeling really dumb.
And I'm like,
why?
What's this blocking?
They're like,
dude,
your blood is like just full of it.
So wow.
So I told critter,
I said,
listen,
I need the kind of trainer that physically abuses me.
Like,
you can put a finger in my ass if you have to.
He has huge hands.
I said,
here's the key.
Here's the key to my house and eat a salad.
Every single.
I told her,
I go,
I don't have that kind of discipline because I don't drink,
I don't do drugs.
And so food is my vice,
especially since I don't gamble anymore.
And it's like I love to eat and I love to eat late at night.
I like to have dinner number two,
dinner number three.
So I said,
here's the key to my house.
I'm every single day I'm going to come up with some excuse to not work out.
Oh,
I got to fuck this girl.
Or I have a really important meeting with Joe Rogan at,
or you know,
it's like,
I don't care.
You have permission to come into my house,
physically dragged me out of my bed,
punched me in my chest and get me to work up because I'm not going to want to.
He's a big dude,
you know?
A big,
yeah.
Well,
he's also,
this is the best part.
Everyone's like,
you have a body guard.
You have that with a joke,
you have a body guard and I go,
yeah,
in the last year,
my,
my two major injuries or from him,
like he almost broke my neck and he broke my ribs broken right now he broke my
rib like two weeks ago when he just,
I don't know what that syndrome is like the,
when a parent loves their babies so much that they shake it and the baby dies.
Like,
cause he has the weekends off.
So when I see him,
he sees me and he picks me up and he always like,
hugs me.
Broke your ribs by shaking.
Well he hugged me and he was shaking me and while he was shaking somewhere,
my friend David Chang tripped him.
Oh No.
But then he fell on top of me.
Oh Jesus.
And he's a big guy.
So I'm like,
yeah,
my,
my body guard that I paid to protect me,
hurts me.
Broke your ribs and almost broke your neck.
How many almost break your neck?
Just when he shakes me like it's so violent that I'm like,
I'm like,
I feel like those students are all movies.
Like,
dude,
one jerk and like my next going to snap and he did it and uh,
and I couldn't turn my head this way for like two weeks and I was like,
like,
can can you like protect me and not hurt me anymore?
You know,
I dunno,
whatever.
What you need is someone who's a Dietitian,
someone is going to be that you can hire like a professional chef.
Kevin James used to have this guy who worked for him.
It was fantastic.
He had this guy working for him all day,
right?
The guy would cook all these meals and he would leave pre prepared,
like really healthy meals in his refrigerator.
Then he hired some woman to do it after that.
All right.
So I did that for a little bit.
Like I've got this,
uh,
see,
this is what I'm talking about.
I,
I don't remember the name of the service,
but they deliver the meal every day.
There's a bunch of those.
Susan's healthy gourmet is one that I used for awhile.
It's like,
yeah.
And I'm like,
cool,
I'm being,
first of all was miserable.
The meal started to stack up in the,
in the refrigerator.
It's like,
oh,
like,
like inside I'd be like,
Oh cool,
I did it.
I'm on this program.
Right.
But then weren't really eating it,
but then I'd look at it or I'd look or I'd eat it and go,
oh cool,
I,
I ate good today.
And then like at three in the morning,
still go out and get the Burrito.
And um,
so the thing I'm doing now,
which I already can see,
um,
it's horrible and everyone says it doesn't work,
but now I'm sort of like stuck in this weird thing is I,
it's like the whole I want,
I'm like,
no one's like,
diets aren't going to work.
Right,
right.
This has to be a lifestyle change,
right?
Like you can't like go for three months eating salads and then be like,
Hey,
I got my weight down,
I got my cholesterol down,
I got my diabetes down.
And then going back to it,
it's like you have to have.
But I'm like,
but I love food.
I love eating.
And so the thing I'm doing now,
which I put,
didn't put too much research into his chewing and spitting.
There's,
I know guys who did that with meat.
There's some MMA fighters.
Like Diego Sanchez was doing that for awhile.
He wouldn't eat meat.
He would just chew it up.
It's horrible for your head.
It isn't really,
it's horrible for you because first of all so you get like,
so I'll,
I'll order like three entrees,
I'll get spaghetti fried chicken,
steak,
I'll get pie,
I'll order everything.
It's just like Roman Times gluttony to the Max.
Right.
And I'll have like the worst is if it's at a nice restaurant cause then they
don't have the,
they have like cloth Napkins and I'm like,
can you bring some more of those paper Napkins?
And I'm sitting there and I'm like are,
and I'm just chewing everything,
getting all the flavor out of it.
And then I'm spitting it,
which the mouth,
as soon as it starts chewing and making saliva,
the stomach starts making acid
to prepare for the food coop to come down.
Right.
But if the food never comes down,
there's just like acid in your stomach,
you know?
And,
and also when you eat,
all the sugar already goes into your,
like before it hits your stomach,
you know?
Yeah.
So I'm eating all this food.
I like nice restaurants and chewing it and spitting and Napkins and then,
and then putting it like on the plate and then the dude's comes sooner.
Is there,
is there something wrong with the meal?
I'm like,
no,
it's delicious.
It's fucking amazing.
And then you know,
you're looking for shortcuts,
bro.
I'm looking for shortcuts.
He can't do that.
Why don't you just hire a real trainer?
Not critter,
but hire someone who's like a real legit strength and conditioning trainer who's
going to put you through some stuff.
If you really want to do something that's fun,
you should or you're fired.
He should take a martial art.
Yeah,
I guess.
I mean you did judo.
I think I need a hot chick.
How would that work for the trainer?
Cause then I'll be motivated and just Kinda wanna fucker.
Well that's then if you can't fuck her,
you want to bring other girls hotter around to show her that you can fuck them.
Like,
listen bitch,
I could fuck them.
Why can't I fuck you and then it will become some weird ego thing and Joe having
an eating disorder is the number one thing to like bond with hot chicks because
they all have one.
I'm like,
should I go a anorexic or chewing and spitting or really overly mia?
And they're like,
well I tried.
I'm like,
cool,
I'm blogging.
It's like all of a sudden like this super boring dumb girl is like all like,
Oh yes,
but a lot of like cross fit chicks.
They don't have eating disorders.
If you get like a strength and conditioning type cow,
you're right Joe.
I do have blood loads of money.
I got to figure out how not a shortcut I just need to figure out to make not
cure cancer,
not cure aids.
Some kind of delicious food that you can eat every day and it's you.
This is the thing.
The more you suffer,
the more you'll enjoy pleasure.
You are a glutton for pleasure,
my friend but you love but here,
check this out.
Technology.
So my,
my Japanese business partner,
I work with this company.
Good smile.
It's not legal in America yet,
but he has,
he smokes,
he drinks,
he eats all this shit.
I don't even know what this process is called.
You might have heard of it but he wants a month.
This is like real rich guy shit.
He gets all like a lot of his blood taken out and then they do shit to it.
Like they make it into super blood and then he puts it back into them and then
all everything goes down.
His,
his,
you know,
and I go,
what is that?
It's not,
it's not FDA,
whatever test it is not in America yet.
And so I do this thing called Regena Kane and I have done today actually on my
shoulder had been bothering me.
They take,
they take your blood out and they spin it in a centrifuge and apply heat to it.
And so your blood thinks like it has a fever and it creates this anti
inflammatory response and creates this like yellow serum on and they extract the
yellow serum out of your blood and then they inject it directly in areas where
you have inflammation.
Oh really good for a injuries.
Right.
But it's also like when you do it like I did it today,
energy,
you just feel great.
Like go gray right now.
Dana White told me about it cause he has a inner ear infection,
uh,
an issue rather called [inaudible] disease and it's from um,
he got beat up one time when he was young but a bunch of guys and is,
he gets this tonight,
it's like ringing in his ear and it fucks with his balance and shit and it's all
inflammation.
Well they figured out a way to inject this,
this,
this serum made out of your blood and it totally cured it for him.
He went through surgeries,
he was on medication,
he did a bunch of shit that really fucked with them.
But this stuff instead of fucking with them,
it uses your own blood and it made him feel fantastic.
And he used to have to go to Germany for it and I was going to fly to Germany.
You go do this.
But then they started opening these places around.
Now they have one lifespan medicine in Santa Monica.
I did this morning.
Well this is what I'm talking about,
Joe.
It's like,
I get the whole like,
you need to suffer to like,
you know,
but,
but that's for injuries.
I know,
but it's like,
do you have any injuries you could use as an excuse to get this?
I'm just saying like the way technology's going now.
Like you're,
you're covered in tattoos,
but like,
you know,
in five years they're going to have some ray that just gets rid of all your
clarity.
Do they have lasers?
I drag them out.
It's not good right now,
but what's painful?
But it will get in and they'll make it so it's not,
you know,
they're going to have everything.
So,
you know,
so I'm like,
do I need to like really switch my eating habits?
Are they gonna make like a,
you know,
some oculus rift fake hamburger where I'm like,
oh yeah,
it's delicious and not,
you know,
I don't know.
This is my take on it.
I think gluttony and eating like lots of delicious food is fun,
right?
But feeling like shit is not fun.
And what I like to do is have cheat days.
What I like to do is I really like,
this is what I've eaten today so far.
I had a,
a blended juice drink,
which was like celery,
ginger,
carrot,
a cucumber.
I'm trying to remember all the,
a Cayenne pepper,
Oregano oil,
lemon,
all this stuff.
Fantastic for you.
Right?
That's what I had for breakfast.
And the only thing I,
I it this morning is today unshaved Pussy Lips,
slight hint of urinary tract infection that's I have today.
And I feel great.
I don't know if you're going to feel great and a couple of hours once the
fucking infection kicks in,
but,
but I got an iron stomach.
I gotta go to fucking in and out Burger man.
I'll fuck ups.
I had Popeye's chicken last night,
dude.
And so because you ate that,
that's why you gotta hit this weird ginger drink.
I eat primarily healthy.
Right.
Primarily healthy.
But then occasionally I go off the rails.
Right.
But most of the time my body's getting healthy food.
That's the key because you feel better,
man,
and you will feel better.
I feel great.
You'll feel better.
You'll have more energy.
I drink these blended Kale shakes in the morning and making myself,
I throw Kale,
tastes like shit.
It's like,
Shit,
don't you use the spinach?
You can do that too,
but I like Kale.
Okay.
It's a superfood or spinach.
A superfood too.
They're all good,
but I failed to hit up kills hip or and fucking strong.
It's,
he's got a lot of nutrients in it.
It's really good for you.
What's better?
Kale or spinach?
Probably with the,
probably Kale because it's a little darker.
A little green.
That's the key.
Like dark green leafy vegetables.
They have fido nutrients
and all sorts of vitamins and stuff and you'd get something out of them.
First of all,
when I eat,
I'm like,
I'll have a bowl like this.
Hi.
Like,
I'm,
I'm pointing to my about 10 inches.
Like a big fucking salad bowl that you would give to like a family.
Like,
Oh,
here's our salad and everybody would take a portion.
I blend that whole mother fucker up.
I drink that shit myself with four cloves of garlic.
I throw a whole apple in there.
Ginger,
I throw a chunk of ginger,
like a,
a thumb size chunk of ginger.
It's just everybody else who tastes it goes,
what the fuck are you drinking?
But Dude,
I throw that shit down and it's like rocket fuel.
I feel great.
I feel fucking fantastic.
It's better than coffee.
I have like a Tereso Bacon Burger.
And then,
and then,
and then I take the top bun off and I go,
yes,
I'm doing good today.
You got rid of that gluten and then I feel supercharged to take a nap.
And I'm like,
yes,
you,
you know,
I think you're enjoying your success and you're enjoying your wealth and your
joint pleasure.
And that's a part of who you are.
And it's also,
I think one of the things about artists is artists are very indulgent.
I'm putting that about my comedian friends and you know,
and yeah,
you were very indulgent.
Self destructive,
your natural comedian,
you are a natural standup comedian.
You,
you did a thing at,
was it at Ucla?
You did a thing at Ucla that you put on that video that was up there.
A bunch people,
dude,
that was like a guy who have been doing standup for years and you had only done
it like how many times when you did that was the first time.
And there's time.
That's shit's ridiculous.
Dude.
Should I plug that?
Fuck yeah.
All right.
So I'm gonna put it on my Twitter.
It's on Twitter.
If you can find it.
My,
my,
uh,
my problem with the Internet is I,
I always think it's like the wild west when it's actually not,
so almost everything I put up on youtube or,
or a Vimeo gets flagged.
I just put up a new episode of my show DVDs and they got flag.
So it gets flagged for what?
Just there's nakedness,
nakedness or whatever.
I mean,
I think in the,
so you took a,
you change your DVD asa page.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like Wikipedia now,
dude.
It's that anybody can go on there and change it.
Now they could say Dave's a fag or whatever and it'll,
you know,
I can't believe I just said,
good luck.
They're going to do that now you did.
You made a Wikipedia out of it.
We used to do that.
We used their technology and we just was like,
if some,
it's like it's,
it's your website now.
How would you do that?
Cause who cares?
You're going to care once your website is all black dicks.
I know that's what's going to happen.
So whatever threat level,
I love the current threat level vitamin PISS yellow as the current threat level,
so everything on that website right now it's the fans did it.
Oh that's great.
Yeah.
I'm like,
fuck it.
I'm not even going to maintain my own website.
Like you had a thing where you got offline.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you took down your,
your podcast and you put up this fucking,
this clan.
I had to,
I had a text you about it immediately once I read it,
because I was alone.
It was like two o'clock in the morning.
I'm in my house and I'm howling laughing cause you're talking about racism,
but you said something to this totally true,
right?
You're
like everyone's afraid of the yellow man,
like black men get to fuck.
But how come Jackie Chan never got the finger bang or fuck in in rush hour one,
two or three?
And I'm like,
it's true Jackie can't Chan like he's safe.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing.
It's um,
I'm in bed fucking this white girl and I had my phone like mixed to her head
like this and it's a text comes in and this is Joe just saying like,
ha ha ha.
He's like,
he's like writing my a press release back to me and it's look,
wait,
first of all,
one quote,
you go,
oh so fucking funny.
I look,
I'm just,
I didn't know these kinds of facts but like do you know how many Asians are in
America?
Like I'm talking about Jungle Asians,
like Japanese,
Korean,
Filipino,
like all of the agents combined.
Do you know how much,
how many of them there are in America?
Know what's taken tick.
Tick a guess 20 million or or percentage wise?
Oh,
percentage.
Yeah.
20 million would be what?
Less than 10% 8% it's 4% 4% it's 4% so it's like
I just like,
you know,
I like doing,
I just like doing shit and you know,
and then people always,
they need to be like,
oh,
check out this Asian comedian or check out this Asian artists for.
And I'm like,
why can't I just be an artist?
What can I just be an artist?
Why do I always have to be like,
you know,
like a mugged by a black guy.
Right,
exactly.
Never.
I dude,
this dude fucking mugged me man.
If you say you got mugged by a dude that was a white guy.
Right.
You know,
if I got fucking mugged by this dude.
Yeah.
And you know,
also Cura,
she's on my shoulder.
The first time I met her was seven or eight years ago.
And so this is still in the year,
you know,
it was like 2005 2006 and it was on the set of the first Asian American Porno in
America.
And I was like,
I don't,
the first one,
I was like,
I don't even know what that means.
And I'm like,
there's Asian chicks and porn.
And it was like,
no,
the first porno in America where they're,
they're all Asian.
And I'm like,
what the male pro?
I'm like,
yeah,
that exists.
And they're like,
no,
it doesn't,
the goal,
the only place in porn where you see an Asian guy is gay porn and he's the
bottom.
So he's literally getting fucked in his ass.
And that's the only place you see them.
So what about Japanese porn?
No,
but that's in Japan,
I'm saying in America and I'm like,
wow,
2005,
whatever.
And that still doesn't exist yet.
And so I go on the set and then the guy that's the performers,
Filipino and I'm like,
that doesn't even count,
you know,
Asian?
No,
they count them.
Just joking.
Um,
but so I go,
wow,
that's weird.
And then,
and then I just,
you know,
the Shit I talk about on my show,
the Shit I just do.
And then I just,
it's like if you talked about,
it would be fine.
If a black guy talks about it,
but it's just,
it brings out like this,
these people and they just,
they're so offended by it and I go,
what?
You know,
and I,
and I know in the script for Romeo must die gently kisses aliyah at the end,
but they changed it to,
they just danced together.
And you know,
Jackie Chan is the star of rush hour of fucking dollar franchise.
Why doesn't he get the fuck or Finger Bang in?
Why not?
Like,
okay fine,
he didn't get to do it in one,
maybe in two he gets to fuck all right.
Will,
you know,
it's like,
why,
why can't,
why can't they be sexual?
You know,
and I don't know the answer to that.
The male,
the male Asian with the white woman is such a rare combination in movies and in
television.
It's so fucking rare that when they're doing it almost feels like they're doing
it on purpose.
Right.
And it's like,
but you know,
cause there was once that have with the black guys are like black guys,
you know,
if I see you as white women were going to kill you.
But now it's like John was fever.
Yeah.
So it's a disease.
I know my,
my best guest on it is when,
and this is just my guess,
is when,
when,
when I hear people go,
Oh man,
there's fucking Asians are like,
they're taking over all this best spots at all the best universities and they're
owning all the real estate and China's taken over the world.
It's like they're taking everything.
They can't take our white pussy on top of that,
you know?
So I dunno.
I Dunno what it is,
but I just know like when I do shit,
like I get a lot more slack for it then,
but whatever,
I don't,
I don't give a shit.
Well,
the point that you were making,
I mean,
I know you were just being funny,
but the point you were making,
it's true.
I mean,
you don't see Asian guys get laid in movies and if they do,
it's with an Asian girl.
I mean,
I'm sure there's examples.
There's one Steven Yeun from walking dead.
That was,
that's true.
That's the only one.
That's a perfect example,
mags.
Pretty God.
Damn,
that's a good one.
That's a good one.
That was,
I high five them for that.
That's a victory for the Asian and he stayed alive for many seasons.
Yeah.
So he's doing it.
Wait,
can I just plug the thing really quick is the thing,
the video,
it's,
well it's vid me,
vid.
Dot.
Emmy.
Cause like I've been looking forever cause everyone's like,
why don't you just have your own platform or whatever.
And I'm like,
I don't want to spend time doing that.
So it's hire somebody.
Well I mean it just like when you do it yourself,
it always cry.
I don't know.
I don't want to,
for me to have less employees,
it's not even the money thing.
Right?
Like I don't want to become a manager,
you know?
Right.
So this,
these,
these kids had started this thing vid me,
which is like my answer to youtube or whatever and I could put anything up
there.
So I put my comedy special.
So if you go to vid.me and then put in DVD or subscripted DVD,
I say you have my comedy special,
which is the first time I did comedy at Ucla,
which is inner cut with like machine guns and girl's butt holes and like Lisa
stuff,
me slapping and cigarettes out of smoking vaginas and there was a lot of stuff,
stuff that you can't put anywhere.
Stuff like here.
Can I give you a great example of like,
well first of all talk about Instagram.
I went on years and like someone found their high school drawing art like Oh
yeah,
I mean you,
you have the frenetic energy of like you got like that Bernie Wrightson and like
you have like you got all the,
you were like good.
I was pretty good.
Yeah,
you were pretty good and yet all you like went crazy with the detail.
Whenever I see a young guy with like lots of detailed like that motherfuckers,
a lot of energy that's usually from like ray,
especially in the subject matter,
like the rage growing every fucking hair on the Werewolf's face whenever the
teeth with the glistening with the fucking blood and whatever.
Lots of obsessed with comic book art.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's great.
I mean,
I think from what I saw,
yeah.
From what I saw.
And how old were you when you do that?
Somewhere in high school?
Probably 15 or 16 that's what I'm saying.
Like you stopped at some point,
right?
I had an asshole fucking art teacher,
man.
He wasn't looked.
I don't,
I feel bad for the dude because he was,
it was clearly a Dork.
Right.
You know,
and,
but he,
that's great.
He had this way of talking about shit where he just killed all your dreams.
I taught like I would draw all like Conan the barbarian and Ninjas and that's an
werewolves and I would draw shit that I would like to teach bullshit teenage boy
shit.
Yeah,
I would do,
I did a whole series.
I love that.
That's a little red riding.
I did a whole series of,
uh,
like little kid stories that went wrong.
The three little pigs is a werewolf.
Fucking just attacks the pigs.
I had Humpty Dumpty,
I pulled that one up.
Eventually.
Humpty dumpty with the ax.
You're an artist.
Yeah.
Well I certainly was.
That's what I was going to do for a living until I started fighting.
And then when I started fighting I became completely obsessed with that cause it
was so primal and so much different than anything else I'd ever done.
This is,
see we have the same story up until then,
or even up until then,
because in high school I drew like that too,
like crazy detail or whatever.
And then I started fighting too and I loved it and I,
and then I started fighting all the time,
except I never won 90% of the fights.
I get my ass.
I still love it.
I'd be like,
yeah,
let's fuck these dudes up.
You mean like fighting like on the street?
You know,
I had a lot of anger.
I didn't do that.
Oh,
you mean fighting?
Yeah,
I don't,
you had like one fight in high school and it wasn't really much of a fight.
Well,
one other time where a d this is the best one.
Um,
was uh,
the most important one for me.
It was this dude,
we wouldn't even like fighting.
It's like he was this kid,
like they bust these,
uh,
these black kids and from bad neighborhoods,
Newton south high.
And there was this one kid and me and him,
we still look at each other like in the hallway and like,
you know,
he would stare at me and I would stare him that nothing really happened.
But then one day we were in the locker room together and I was passing him.
He looked at me and uh,
I don't remember what was said,
but I remember the dude grabbed me and hip toss me down to the ground,
throw me on my back and held me down and he was thinking about punching me.
He was like holding me,
my like,
and just held me and then let me up.
I was totally humiliated,
totally humiliated.
He said the n word with the Er?
No,
no,
no.
I didn't see anything of Kimmy.
I think I said like what the fuck you know,
or something like when he was home,
but I realized,
shit,
I don't know how to wrestle.
I think I was probably 14 I was like,
God damn it.
I don't know.
I need to learn how to read.
This is humiliating feeling you like I,
I don't want to ever feel that it was terrible.
I had never had taken like a couple of karate classes then,
but
know grappling whatsoever.
Right.
So at the same time I joined the wrestling team and I started getting really
serious about taekwondo at the very same time.
It was because of that dude.
Like I owe him.
He,
he made me who I became like for real because he humiliated the shit out of me.
You know,
like that changed your course down that path.
But if that never happened and you stuck with the art,
I mean that looks,
I mean that looks pretty good.
Well,
I enjoyed art.
I still do.
I still draw.
I was draw,
draw,
draw like that.
Yeah.
I could still do it like that.
I mean do electronic crosshatching and all that stuff.
Yeah.
I love cross hatching.
I love,
I love deep.
I like to do um,
like pencil and then ballpoint pen over the pencil.
That's like my favorite style of,
I have some other stuff that I'll put up that I did like that I want to check it
out.
Cause like technical pens,
I always found to be like a little too permanent.
Like I like seeing,
like though I feel like with a ballpoint pen you could sorta almost barely touch
the paper and the image just starts to slowly come out.
Do this with your kids.
Ballpoint pen drawn bananas.
Like that sensation of a ballpoint pen on a banana is like the best thing.
And then like the next day when the,
the,
the banana peel dries up,
the drawing looks different.
My kids love art.
Yeah.
It's a fun thing.
But my progression was,
was the same thing.
Everything in high school was this shit like crosshatching pen,
pencil,
prisma colors.
And then,
um,
you know,
I discovered spray paint,
which was like the fucking,
like the best thing ever.
It's like,
oh my God,
I discovered the Matrix,
you know,
and then,
um,
uh,
acrylic and oil paint.
But what I discovered now after painting and drawing for years is that
all those things I just said,
spray paint oil,
acrylic is you just even pencils.
Like you draw something,
you create something and if you don't like it,
you just paint over it,
you just erase it.
And then,
uh,
the new thing that like,
I just,
this is like,
like alchemy or like painting with,
with magic is the watercolor.
It's like,
it's like the medium in art that has like,
I,
I'd probably say like the least amount of respect because it's like,
oh,
watercolor,
you think of like old ladies,
you know,
on some ways that,
I dunno,
but like this whole book that I did is all watercolors.
It's like 300 pages of watercolors.
And I'm like,
you know,
I'm a pretty well respected artists now.
Like I should be able to get this thing published.
I shouldn't have to like self publish it and I don't want to self publish it.
That's like in the same way,
like I don't want to put up my own,
uh,
what do you call like of um,
um,
I don't want to start my own youtube or whatever.
Like I just would rather to do the art and have like a respected publication,
put it out.
So I turned the book in and start this book bidding war with all the published,
all the cool artsy publishers don't want to put it out.
And I'm like,
Dave,
you got to take these four pages out.
You know,
our legal team looked at it and you know,
I guess there's obscenity laws.
Like you can't put an ar 15 in a girl's butthole.
And I go,
but I thought,
you know,
it's hard.
Well,
it's art.
And I thought like,
we lived in America,
I thought you do whatever,
you know,
and I keep,
I don't know,
I guess I keep pushing things and finding out that you can't do them,
but you can,
you can,
you just can't do it in their forum.
Right.
That's all it is.
And I go,
what's the problem?
They're like,
we might get sued.
I go,
well by who?
I don't know.
It's always like this preemptive like this imaginary fear and I go,
we need people like you out there.
I go look like,
and I was excited cause I was like,
oh these are like the publishers that I like,
I would love to work with you.
And I go,
oh so I,
you know,
I put the book out myself and it's like we sold it out like the special edition
right away.
If you want to get it to that David show.com but it's,
we made so much money on it,
on the,
I don't want to say this like I'm bragging,
but it's like I didn't even want to make that money.
Right?
Like I would rather someone else to make that money.
I just wanted to put it out.
But it's like they wouldn't do it.
So you had to do it yourself.
And that,
that's sort of,
I bring that up because I'd rather just,
it's so easy to just do a video on and throw it up on Youtube.
That's so easy.
I don't want to fucking find,
you know,
it's like I just want to make shit and just put it out there,
but everything I do gets taken down.
So I just gotta you know,
it's just you are,
you are an unusual guy and an unusual,
an unusual situation and you want it to be free.
You want to be free to express yourself.
And you know,
someone could say like,
Oh fuck him and he's this and he's that and he's arrogant and he's this.
But no,
you're,
you,
you're being free.
You're not worried.
You're not being a fake.
You are actually doing things that you're interested in.
And in a lot of ways this isn't,
we is a real problem that we have in society with needing someone to publish
your stuff.
Because if you need someone to publish your stuffed and they're going to have to
approve it and then you're not going to get the original vision of the artist or
the writer or whatever,
you're going to get a bunch of other people's in pink opinions of what you
should broadcast when you should publish.
Well look,
can I ask you this because you are like,
since I first did your show,
I think the first time I ever did you show,
I'd never been on TV.
And since I've been on,
I mean you,
you,
you have like a long career in TV,
you fear factor or the UFC stuff.
And so I've been on TV twice now.
I did Anthony Bourdain shows,
parts unknown and I did,
um,
I do the news for Hbo,
for Vice Hbo and both shows that I've been on one Emmy's and like,
it's like everything I do doesn't have to be guns in buttholes.
Right.
You know,
I can work,
they can do with it.
They're like,
Hey,
do do comedy but don't cuss.
And then I could do it.
But,
so the two times I did TV,
like it's like,
oh,
David,
those shows you won,
won,
won Emmy's.
And so the floodgates sort of open in like,
now I have all these people interested in doing shows with me and,
but there,
do you ever have this experience?
Because then,
you know,
you know a lot,
a lot of rich people and whatever.
Like I sit in board rooms with like CEOs and people that run these companies and
they're billionaires and they run the world.
They have way more money than me.
They have way more power,
fame,
whatever.
And they're still not free men.
They're the answer to,
to,
to AOL Disney or I don't know.
Like they,
they go,
uh,
you,
yeah,
like you gotta take these four P's.
I'm not afraid to take chances.
I go,
you're a fucking billionaire who like,
who gives a shit?
It's like,
Oh wow,
you have all the money in the world yet you still have to answer to
shareholders.
Like your business partners,
your wife.
I don't know.
I made a conscious decision not to get married.
I don't have kids.
I don't work for anybody.
And so it's like,
man,
it would be so easy for me to just sign this deal and do this TV show.
But then they're like,
but then you can't have Han dynasty on your team that don't ever let anybody
take you from doing what you're doing.
Well,
no one says,
well the nice thing is no one says you can't do it.
They just go,
if you want to be on our team,
then you can't do this shit.
Like what is this Hong Dynasty saying you can't do it.
Look,
I haven't heard that one,
but I don't projects before with have told me to take down my website,
take down your message board,
take time.
Like fuck you.
Right.
I'm not taking out shit because if you want me to do that,
you want me to compromise myself.
That's going to start there and it's going to end up with me wearing a fucking
suit,
sitting behind a desk,
talking to some idiot about his sitcom that I could give two fucks about what
happened.
And it's a weird thing cause it's like I didn't give a shit.
Then when I was poor,
I didn't give a shit when I was rich.
And then it's like,
what now I'm going to have a boss.
Like it's weird,
like you don't have to do that.
Just do things that you're doing now.
This is what I'm saying that I know,
but this is what I'm saying Joel,
like I don't want like,
well what's a bet?
Let's put it this way.
What's the benefit of you doing something on television other than vice,
which is an awesome show and Anthony Bourdain show,
which is an awesome,
things like that is great,
but what's the benefit of you doing a television?
Do you need more money?
You don't know what to do with money.
It's just like to do projects.
It's just for me like I dunno,
I just film this pilot where just,
yeah,
it's not for the money.
They don't even have to pay me anything.
But it's like I get to fly somewhere and I get to like,
like doing a show like this.
We can say anything we want or we could talk about like,
oh,
I want to make this movie and talk about the ideas,
but this is like making it happen.
You know?
It's like,
but you could do that.
I know,
but it's like the thing with the publishing,
it's so much easier for like when I showed up on board,
ain't set like it's all taken care of.
I was like,
wow.
This producer called everyone does camera man's like a award winning
cinematographer.
He knows what he's doing.
Like I don't want to become the guy that's like,
oh,
I got to start my own network now.
I've got to hire my own guys and do all this shit to,
you can do that though,
man.
You can have meetings and this is one of the things you could do is get a
manager,
get a nice Jewish boy who understands show business and tell that motherfucker
this is,
this is me.
I'm David Chow.
I like to put ar 15 up curls.
Buttholes I like to do watercolor paintings that are obscene.
I like to do this thing called DVD asa that gets me fired from Hbo.
I'm a crazy man.
Nobody fired,
but I,
you got an option.
We'll talk the talk.
I got tons of money and I'd like to do fun shit and I don't want to have a boss,
but I want to be able to do cool projects.
I want to life,
I want to have adventures.
So what do we need to do to hire a bunch of like real good union cameraman to
set up a real good production studio where we can edit video,
higher legit people.
I don't want to deal with shit.
I just want to go do my stuff.
You handle all that and you could do all that and it can become profitable
easily.
Easily.
Well,
I mean I'm not your manager,
but that's what I'm saying.
It's like,
it's like being a reluctant entrepreneur.
I don't want to do that.
I'm going to have to,
you should,
you know you should get stuff you're doing.
It's Hong Diane.
She's tough.
It's fun.
That was like,
just like,
you know,
it's like,
it's like a weird feeling to go to like a Denzel movie or Liam Neeson movie and
you're sitting there and you're like,
this is shitty,
but you're like,
it's so much money behind it.
How did it even get made?
You know?
Or you're sitting in an editing room and,
and that you're putting in,
you're working on the show and you're like,
wow,
that ports are really funny.
It was like,
that's never going to be on TV.
Why?
Because everyone in this room agrees.
That's the funniest thing.
It'll never be on TV.
Why?
Because of a coasts soap commercial is going to pull their ads if you do that,
that's half the best shit I've ever said on fear factor.
Never made it to the air.
Exactly.
Cause I would fuck with the contestants and save ridiculous shit.
Like to see that wasn't going to be on the air.
I would love to see that.
But you got to understand that that's not what they're trying to do.
Their,
their business is not the business of artistic expression.
Right.
Businesses,
the business of making money.
What's the best way to optimize our chance to make making money?
You got to get a real cookie cutter bullshit television show,
right?
You know these,
but they're saying there's,
then there's no audience for a fear factor type show where Joe Fox with the
contestants there is,
but it's not that forum.
That forum has already been established.
It's already locked down.
It's already censored.
But what you're doing on the,
on the Internet is a wild wet,
like this podcast,
it has no boss.
There's no one to tell us what we can talk about.
We can do whatever we want.
Right.
And it's because it's on the Internet.
You could do that same sort of thing and running to what I do,
which is like,
hey Joe,
you're on.
Like,
you know,
whatever the network UFC is on.
Or you know,
anytime you do TV stuff,
do they ever go,
hey Joe,
I've had a few talks about some fucking crazy shit on your last show.
You've got to take that episode down.
No,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
I wouldn't do it.
I bet we've,
there's been a few issues,
but I can justify the things that I've talked about.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not just going off on a rail you love.
You'll see what I'm saying.
I love it.
Yeah.
I've never met anyone who like knows so much and it just couldn't recall that if
they at one point like Dana white or whoever said,
hey Joe,
you're,
you're like part of UFC.
Like you've been doing it forever.
You're podcast is just,
I quit.
I quit the UFC.
You would like that in one second.
One second.
You didn't say.
I love it so much that I can,
I've come close a couple of times.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm,
there's no way.
I'm not,
I'm never,
I'll never change what I do in stand up and I'll never change what I do with the
podcast.
I firmly believe that if I did that,
I would be a miserable fuck if I decided.
I believe that too.
I'm going to censor the podcast and now I'm not going to have people like David
[inaudible].
He's a fucking loose cannon.
He's talking about Jackie Chan finger banging people.
He's got an ar,
15 is up scores,
girl's butthole.
If I did that,
I would,
I would fuck myself over.
And plus I started doing this thing that I'd like as much as doing the UFC or
started doing these fight companion podcast where we sit down and we watched the
fights.
We put the fight up on there and we drink and you smoke weed and we watched the
fight to just talk while the fights are going on.
It's the most fun recordings and we broadcast it.
You're probably having more fun doing that.
She gets hundreds of thousands of downloads.
Wow.
See these crazy.
I liked doing that almost as much as I like being there,
almost being there as the best.
I mean,
I don't get me wrong,
I love my show and talking about everything.
You know,
fucking Jackie Chan,
like finger blasting and whatever.
But I love getting access to fucking go to,
to the North Pole in and interviewing like the Norwegian army general and
getting,
you know,
I liked that and stuff too.
And it's like,
well,
anytime I'm putting this,
I'm like,
you man.
I'll never fucking never been out to anybody.
Like I don't give a fuck blue,
but at the same time I don't have to do anything,
you know?
Right.
You could just sit down and just chill.
Yeah.
You have what's really fuck you money.
You really have it.
I mean that's a,
that's an expression you have.
Fuck you money.
It feels good.
It does feel good.
You're going to use that fuck you money.
Use it to say fuck you.
And when you,
when you do a television show with a compromise,
you,
hey,
you gotta take down DVD Asa.
Well,
you got to stop doing an ar 15 up girl's butthole pictures,
right?
You automatically,
you,
you get rid of the whole point of having fuck you money.
You can't say fuck you.
Who you are is just weird,
unique artists.
Dude,
who likes doing,
she like pushing boundaries.
You like being open about everything from prostitutes to sexual proclivities to
overeating and diabetes.
But that's you man.
You're a good dude.
You know,
I like you have,
I don't worry about guys like you getting corrupted by the fucking grist for the
mill.
Get stuck in the machine where they figured out,
how can I make more money off of David Choe?
I got to make David,
you know what they did with,
here's a perfect example.
You know what they did with David had the Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle was doing the fucking Chappelle show,
which in my opinion is the greatest sketch show of all time best the best.
He's one of the funniest standup years later we could still watch repeats.
It's funny as shit.
That guy,
the blind white racist,
who was a black guy is still one of the greatest sketches of all the race
trading Chinese taking the Wu Tang clan and brilliant,
brilliant,
brilliant show.
They started telling him he couldn't say nigger.
They started telling him to stop saying it and he was like,
what are you talking about?
They were like,
we can get more money from advertisement if you stop saying this or you stop
saying that or don't do this or do it.
And that's when he went crazy or maybe went sane and decided,
you know what?
I got some money and they had a $50 million offer to fucking renew and this and
that.
And he just said,
fuck this.
He went to Africa,
tried to relax and find himself and came back and he quit the fucking show and
he quit the show because they were turning him into something else,
right?
They were trying to take this
uncensored,
brilliant artistic mind and make him a commodity.
Right?
And that's what happens,
man,
Duh.
But that's their business.
It's not,
that's like,
it's like being alone with a wolf and the wolf eats you when it's hungry.
Of course it's a fucking Wolf,
right?
It's what they do.
It's like you can't be upset at a wolf for eating you.
That's,
that's their nature.
And the nature of people that run these,
these production studios and networks,
they're not evil.
They just make money and the way to make money.
How much money can you get from Toyota will Toyota,
we'll give you x amount of money.
If you don't have any swears,
they'll give you,
you know,
x more if you cut out this and don't do that,
they'll,
they'll sign on for three years.
A three year commitment.
Well that's the way that shit works.
No,
it's just about my nose.
Well,
I,
I've been,
you know,
I've worked every job,
I've worked in advertising,
I've worked,
I've done all that shit.
When I,
when I made the fuck you money,
I sat down and I have five guys that work with me know,
and had a meeting and I said the point of what we do,
and it's never been in the specialty now,
is to not make money.
You know,
I know I could sit here and talk to you about like,
should you turn into subscription base or ads and listen to that.
We've never had ads on my show because I don't have to.
And it's like,
it would be nice if we made stuff that did make money,
but that is never,
you know,
the last three years.
Like everything I do just like hemorrhages and bleeds and money,
but you know,
I can sell one painting and make that money back in one day.
And you know,
it's like
people who have had this discussion before when the,
when they're at 77,
11 buying a scratcher or super lotto ticket and they're like,
man,
if I had $100 million,
this was what I would do.
But it's like in this country and I don't want to go on a diatribe about greed
or whatever.
It's like when is it enough?
Like when is it like,
so you got to show,
uh,
that like the Chappelle show and he wants to say,
nigger,
just let them say it.
Like he feels good.
He's allowed to say it.
Well,
it's like they are not Chappelle,
so,
right when you have people that are not creative people or not,
they're certainly not responsible for his creative vision and they started
interfering with it and trying to monetize it.
Right?
That's when it becomes a problem when it isn't a problem is when you roll is the
artist is in complete control.
Like a podcast,
like your DVD,
a podcast,
or like Han dynasty or any of this other shit you do like all of your paintings,
no one's standing over you and go,
Dave stopped painting tits.
You know you're painting vagina,
you're poor,
you're making women objects,
you're doing this,
you're doing that.
You,
you,
you can't be you.
If that's happening,
look,
maybe some people are going to criticize you and maybe you'll take that
criticism to heart and it'll change your opinion about things,
which is totally honest and fine.
If someone says,
hey,
no,
hey Dave,
I'm tired of you painting,
blah,
blah.
Right?
And then you go,
you know what know?
It's Kinda fun.
I don't want anybody to feel bad,
right?
I'm just trying to express myself.
Maybe I wasn't looking at it from their point of view.
And then you can sort of alter your point of view.
It's not,
it's something negative about that.
It's part of developing,
maturing,
growing,
taking in all sorts of different influences.
It's a part of being human being,
right?
But there's a big difference between that and doing it only for money.
And that's what happens when you get attached to a network and it's not their
fault,
it's just what they do.
But it's why like I've never,
I've never talked to anybody about selling this thing.
I would never sell this thing.
This is just,
this is,
we started this out,
Brian and I go about the day that Howard's a hundred percent fuck everything up,
right?
They'd say,
you gotta Stop Smoking Weed,
right?
You guys got lit joints everywhere.
You can't do that.
What do you mean?
Why can't we,
it's California.
I have a medical marijuana license,
so w and then who gives a fuck?
Anybody?
We have whiskey here all the time and we complains about that.
Like,
what are we complaining about?
This w w th there's millions of people that smoke weed.
He told me that those people's money is not worth anything,
right?
The we dollar is not real money,
You've got to respect the fucking stoner dollar were people I pay taxes,
okay,
I'm going to fucking NRA,
goddammit.
Right?
There's a real problem when people try to take creative ideas and turn those
creative ideas into some sort of a complete monetary,
uh,
venture.
And that's what happens when you get involved with a television show,
right?
It's just what it is.
There's some sort of compromise involved here.
You don't have to do that.
Here's the problem,
Joe.
It's like when I paint something,
it's like,
some people will see it.
If I have it in an art gallery,
I don't go to art galleries.
It's like the spectrum of media is like this,
right?
It's like at the top is network television,
like blockbuster,
Hollywood movies.
And then at video games,
or maybe video games is at the top and then it's like,
uh,
you know,
music and then,
books,
comic books.
And at the very bottom is art,
right?
So at the very top,
there's the most censorship,
there's the most like people with their people involved.
Um,
you can't say this,
you can't do that.
Dolphin Tale two,
right?
And at the very bottom is art where I can paint any,
anything and no one cares.
And it's not literal,
right?
Not only that,
it's a direct connection to the art,
right?
You have your hands on the brush,
You're standing in front of the canvas,
there's no one there and it's alone in your warehouse,
a solitary sport.
No one's involved sort of like jerking off a lot of cross hatching and,
and you draw this thing and it means whatever it means to whoever is,
to me it means this to you.
It means that it's like,
you know,
there's very little chances of you becoming like a fucking billionaire drawing
comic books,
but you know it,
you get to say,
what dollar can you put on freedom like that.
But now because this weird anomaly of where I did make like all this money doing
art,
the floodgates have opened for me to do all types of entertainment.
And not to sound too like
artsy or whatever.
I look at,
everything I do is art.
I look at my podcast,
my TV stuff.
I bring that level of expression and freedom to it.
And then it just is not translating well with the higher ups,
I guess.
And it's like,
Hey,
you could do whatever you want over here,
but there's no higher ops pro.
I know there isn't can all suck you down.
Yeah.
There's no higher ups man.
I mean this all comes down to other people in forensic influencing your,
your creative vision.
And you can't ever let that happen because you create a vision is what makes you
unique.
You know,
when I talked about being an artist or wanting to be an artist in high school
and having this bad art teacher,
I mean,
I honestly do feel bad for the dude because he was really frumpy and he had a
gut and it's,
his fucking posture was bad.
And he just was a guy who just had no hope.
And what he said to me,
it was like I would draw this stuff and he was like,
you got to do like you,
you're going to have to draw things that you don't want to draw.
And I said,
why?
And he said,
because you're going to have to make a living.
So if you're going to have to make a living,
maybe going to work for,
uh,
this is the thing,
the example to use,
you're going to have to draw a babies for a,
a,
a diaper commercial.
And I was like,
but I want to be a comic book artist.
And he's like,
but you're not,
may not make it as a convertible car.
So I was like,
Oh fuck this.
So my senior year I didn't even take art.
I was one of the best artists in his class.
There was me,
this guy,
I think his name's John Devor.
He was really good.
And this Guy Kevin,
who was also really good,
these,
these three guys.
And we always used to draw the same style stuff.
I don't know if they became an artist.
I don't know what happened.
Keep in touch with them.
No,
it was high.
School was weird.
Fucking,
I was such a social misfit and high school.
Do you ever do a
portfolio day where you have like a,
all your drawings and you go to like,
uh,
like Disney or something and
no,
I never got that far with it.
So I don't even get to two as far as like applying to colleges.
When I,
when I got out of high school,
um,
I went to art school for a year or two and then I dropped out and I was just
like,
how am I going to make a living doing this?
And I,
and I got all my best drawings and I went to,
I think it was cal arts,
it was like a,
it's like a open call,
like in,
it's like every single animation studio,
every single advertising agency.
And I got there and it's all these fucking kids with all their art and there's
really long lines to talk to a guy that like has a pencil behind his ear and
goes,
work on this work on this.
And I was like,
fuck this.
And so I was like,
I'm not even gonna wait in this line.
So I went,
I went to go take a piss and I saw one of the advertising guys get up and I
followed him to the bathroom and I said,
I pulled one of those while his Dick's out.
I'm like,
Hey,
look at,
look at this,
cross hatch penis,
look at this.
And he's like,
Hey,
you can't wait in line like everyone else.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm pleased.
And he like looked over,
he was like,
Hey,
that's pretty good.
And so he's got his dick out and a nice fat Dick Dude.
No,
he gives,
he gives me his card and he goes,
you're fucking dope man.
You should come to my office in Beverly Hills.
And I was like either 20 or 21.
And I was like,
yes.
And it's the,
it's one of the biggest advertising agencies in La.
I show up there like with a tie on and everything.
And as I walked down the hallway,
it's like every movie poster.
And uh,
I was like,
I made it.
I'm fucking like young and I'm going to make a living drawing.
Like this is fucking crazy.
So I think back then,
I don't know how it is now.
They would have all these artists draw in.
Um,
the style I forgotten drew Struzan,
that's that star wars.
Uh,
they got painted all the star wars.
These guys all draw that same style and you'd draw the movie poster and then
they give that to the photographer and the photographer because you know,
there's no art in movie posters now.
Right.
And this is,
I'm talking about fucking 20 years ago,
so I'm sure it's different now.
And it was a avalanche movie with Chris Dawn.
No.
Crystal.
Donald.
Crystal Donald,
I think if the movie was called avalanche.
Yeah.
And so I sat in the room and I was like,
this is so cool.
I get to see a movie before it came out,
you know?
And I'm like,
this movie fucking sucks.
And then I'm sitting there watching it with like six old guys with like
cigarettes daily dangling out of their mouth.
And I'm like,
all right guys,
we need avalanches.
We need this and this and we need Chris O'donnell looking like this.
And I'm like,
this is amazing.
You know?
And I sit in a room and I draw Chris O'donnell and there's a poster,
vertical,
vertical limit.
There it is.
I think I drew that Bill Paxton.
Well that's what you do.
Yeah,
that's pretty exact.
Willem defoe was the guy in the back.
I don't remember who was that?
Glenn Scott Glenn.
Oh,
that guy.
Yeah,
he's,
that guy is awesome.
So I got all of their headshots,
I'm drawing them,
the art directors coming in and he's like,
you know,
it's,
I mean he,
he starts with the compliment Dave.
That's great.
Can you do it again?
Like a little bit smirk,
a little bit more heroic and then,
um,
not even a day in,
I'm like,
I hate this job.
I just drew fucking Chris O'donnell and same thing at the same thought.
Then I'm like,
how did this movie get made?
Right?
Like,
it's horrible.
like who?
Like,
like why don't crystal,
Donald's a beautiful man.
I just want to see him.
Right.
It's a good date night movie.
And so I already safe.
I lasted at that job,
you know,
when you say like you got to draw shit,
like yeah.
The next one was like a Sandra Bullock movie where she's an alcoholic,
the 28 days or something.
And you know that,
that whole like,
Hey,
I'm somewhat part of show Biz and I'm working and I'm making the good money.
I walked into the guy's office less than a month in.
I said like,
thank you for this honor.
Like I appreciate it like this.
I learned so much I can't do it.
He's like,
what are you talking about?
Like why did you see that line?
You see how many people would die?
He's like,
Dave.
And he closes the door.
He was like,
I'm going to tell you something.
You remind me of me.
Like 20 years ago,
the fucking crazy hair you got like that fucking punk rock attitude.
If you stay here and you do what I tell you,
you could be running this fucking place in like 20 years.
And it was like,
and I was like,
oh well you only gave me a nice ego.
Boost the devil.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
I wonder if he said this to all those guys out there,
you know.
And cause I was the youngest guy there and I go,
I can't even believe I'm telling you.
Like,
like I said,
thank you for this opportunity.
I can't do this though.
I can't,
like,
I feel like art is my passion.
I love it.
I feel like I'm dying here,
you know?
Cause I thought,
oh,
I could draw Krystle Donal all day.
And then at at night I could draw whatever I want.
Ar 15 is in buttholes,
right?
Muscle memory.
I had just spent the entire day training my hand to draw into drew Struzan style
of Chris O'donnell.
I get home and I want to do my shit.
And I'm like,
Oh fuck that butthole looks like crystal with Donald's face.
You know?
So I tell the guy,
go,
hey,
look,
I can't believe this great opportunity you gave me,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to have to regretfully decline this thing.
And he goes,
oh,
what are you going to do Dave?
Draw your funny books.
He didn't say it in that voice,
but he's like,
he's like,
well,
it's not like hardcore,
but he's like,
what are you going to do?
And he's like,
good luck with that.
And I was like,
you know what I,
I've made at that young at that,
it's,
it's the,
it's for me the saddest thing when I see young people that have already given,
and I'm like,
that's the time you fight.
That's the time that you should try and fail and try again.
And then it's like when you get old you're like,
at least I tried.
It didn't work out,
you know?
So I said,
look man,
I'm going to go for it and if I end up fucking broke or poor,
whatever,
then fuck it,
you know?
At least I tried,
you know,
and,
and the next next job from that was drawing a midgets and,
and buttholes for Hustler.
So I was like,
yes,
I get to at least draw what I want to draw and buttholes for hostler yeah,
worked for like Asian fever and the whole Larry Flynt trying to monetize a
creative vision.
It's,
it's always,
it's,
it's really important that you try to figure out what is unique in your head and
that what is in your head,
how do you get it out?
And if you want to bring up the Chappelle show or anything,
it's like this whole like,
I don't want to start my own network.
I don't want to start my own publishing company.
It's like I'm just going to do whatever I want,
knowing that it's not gonna make any money.
And then what always happens is because it's so unique and whatever,
it does make money.
Oh that's so easy for you now Dave,
cause you have fuck you money.
I'm like,
how do you think I got it?
How do you think I fucking got it?
It does still be working for that advertising.
Right,
exactly.
I take the chance when I had nothing and it had nothing to nude.
They say the rich and the poor have more in common than the middle class because
they both like if you're poor,
you're like,
Hey,
I've got nothing to lose.
If I get sued or whatever,
I'm like,
they could take my fucking toilet paper roll or whatever,
you know?
So I dunno,
you look,
you're not trying to make money.
You have money.
So if you're not trying to make money,
it's really simple.
It's like you just need a manager,
someone to come along and take care of her.
I got us be creative.
Yeah.
I got a great manager.
I got great people working with us.
I've got a great personal trainer.
My rib check out this painting.
Tell me what you think about that.
Um,
it's,
it's beautiful.
Uh,
Lance Joe just showed me a painting of a beautiful snow mountain landscape with
trees in the style of like Bob Ross who want hear sound crazy.
My six year old did that.
Shut the fuck up by watching one of those Bob Ross things?
No,
she just takes art class though.
You fucking kidding.
She's very talented.
She's been doing art since she was really little.
Is this oil paint or what?
Yeah,
I got with her when she was really little too.
Uh,
we sit down
and do a lot of art together.
She's talented.
I got my art from my uncle.
I got it from my family.
My grandmother was talented.
My uncle's talented.
My,
my uncle's an artist.
Right.
It's all just,
it's,
it's in the family.
You know what I think about when I see that it's like,
have you ever seen,
this is going to sound bad,
but have you ever seen Hitler's art?
Yes,
I have.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's good,
but it's very like you would think a guy that is a murderer and like his
murdered,
like millions of people would have like a more hardcore,
you know,
it's like that's great if you're six years,
like first of all the thing Joe just show me,
look like a grown adult.
It freaks me out.
The the mountains and the snow in the mountains
when you're at that age,
like the tiger woods,
Michael Jordan,
like young person and like you're,
you're learning,
you're like Picasso or whatever.
Like you're learning,
you're,
I'm just technique techniques and just getting all that stuff down perspective.
You get it down and you're like,
wow,
I can paint a tree with all the highlights off the leaves and the dew drops in
and that's great.
That's like the time to do that.
But then at some point you have to be like,
what's inside me?
Is it really a landscape or do I want to paint some crazy shit and I,
yeah,
and so like she's great.
She has the potential like everyone has the potential.
Right.
But they get to a point,
it's like you discovered fighting,
but if you never got into fighting,
I think you would have been a great artist doing,
you know all your werewolves
well why would have enjoyed it?
I still love comic book movies and I Love Comic Book Art.
Like I love those like really glossy comic book magazines and stuff.
So like when I see Hitler's are nicely like these landscapes and just shit,
I'm like dude,
if you like went as hardcore and your art as you did with killing people,
like maybe you would have never become a,
you know,
did you see the thing that was out recently about Hitler taking math like Hitler
apparently was like really in the math sounds about right.
Sounds about right.
Yeah.
There was some screaming and he was on Meth,
the adult rent.
He was apparently a hypochondriac and he took a bunch of different medications.
But one of them is he,
he took math.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Which totally makes sense.
Right.
That was the,
one of the things they say with math is that a completely corroded your
judgment.
Your judgment just goes out the window.
He just killed Jews.
Each kills
those crazy speeches.
He's probably meth to the tits.
Wow.
Probably didn't have any nerves at all.
That's why he was so intense and fucking hair flopping around furious anger in
his eyes.
Yeah.
That's,
you watch one of his,
yeah,
Hitler was on crystal meth and I crazy.
What's that website?
Is that USA Today?
Yeah.
Well,
according to a 47 page,
I can't read that bull.
Same.
Sorry.
Military dossier.
He used to take bull semen,
morphine,
tranquilizers,
bull semen.
Hmm.
I don't think that did anything for him.
But the crystal Meth,
a pill that contain crystal meth and other drugs depending on Hitler's.
Have you ever seen a Kevorkian art?
No.
It's fucking crazy.
He is.
Fuck.
Well,
you'd imagine.
Yeah,
but like makes you sort of rethink like his motivation.
Have you ever seen George Bushes aren't?
Yes.
It's fucking awesome.
Him looking in the mirror.
Have you seen that one?
Looking at Kevorkian art.
Pull up some of the more dark,
it's all like death stuff,
which is really kind of fucked up man.
It's like he was really into like,
wow.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
look at that man.
That's like demonic shit.
It's a guy being pulled into the abyss and you see eyeballs behind him and
stuff.
Jesus.
But there's some other ones that are even more disturbing than that,
Jamie.
There's like some like dead body ones and shit.
Don't get it.
Like,
look at this.
Look at this one.
What the fuck is this man?
Look at this.
So Dude's sitting at a plate,
a at a dinner.
Guys went on the blitz going on here.
It's okay.
Zoom up again.
It's just good to see the whole thing.
It's a Roman soldier.
He's smirking.
He's,
um,
he's,
the guy has his head to capitated.
There's a bowl of what?
Jewish stars,
the Star of David.
And then there's like what the f and the salt and pepper Shaker or like rocket
ships.
Is that what's going on?
Fucking crazy.
The guy's got an apple,
the guy's head is cut off.
It's on a plate.
There's an apple in his mouth.
Okay.
So let me ask you,
Joe,
you,
you have your show where you get drunk and you critique UFC fights.
You have this show you all these forms of expression,
you have to stand up,
stand up comedy every night.
Do you think like art is like the best?
Like not for like uh,
like monetizing reasons or fans or whatever.
Just when I draw something and I expressed them and I don't have to like write
literally and I just go wow.
And that,
that fucking breast stroke,
it captures exactly what's going on.
Isn't that like the best feeling?
Like I don't know what's going on in the Kevorkian Shit,
but that must guy,
it must have had so much shit that like that release of like painting shit like
that is just like,
it's so therapeutic to me.
Like yeah,
there's definitely something beautiful about creating something cause you know
that like it didn't exist before you put your attention to it.
You put your attention to that piece of paper or that piece of clay or whatever
you're creating and you,
you made something out of it and it existed because you put your attention to it
and whatever it is inside of you,
right?
Whatever.
Creativity is undefined,
you're,
you're God creating something out of nothing.
You know,
like there's nothing here and you create it.
And then like just not to harp on it or sound,
you know,
it's just with the young people,
cause I'm sure young people talk to you all the time and I don't,
I don't want to sound delusional saying,
oh,
it's easy for you or guys like Joe.
But the saddest thing is when you enslave yourself at such a young age and throw
yourself into like,
yes,
there's people that need to be parking meter cops,
there's people that need to be working at an ad agency,
but it doesn't need to be you.
It doesn't need to be me,
but it needs to be the person who's listening to me that I'm saying it doesn't
need to be you.
It doesn't need to be you.
There's a lot of fucking people,
man.
Right.
And somebody will fall prey to that trap.
This is,
this is like my best advice on
that whole thing.
It's,
yeah,
there's people that fall in that trap.
It's like you're young,
you can fuck up and you'll still be young like and then try again.
And it's like I get,
you know,
I'm sure you have a lot of people that are like your fans.
They go,
you did it and I,
you're my idol and I worship you and this and that and so you did it.
So that makes me feel like I can do it.
And my whole thing with that is
like the whole like follow your dreams,
definitely follow your dreams.
You know like definitely go for it.
Like your dreams and everything.
But like what gets my dick really hard,
it's like when I'm at Ihub and the guy takes my pancake order and he's like,
you know,
we have three new different syrups for that.
And like if you do this,
that's a better combo.
And he knows his job and he runs to get me the syrup and I'm like,
this guy maybe doesn't want to be,
I hope a waiter for his whole life,
but the time he's here,
he's passionate about it.
He's bringing all of his energy to it.
And then if I hop waiters and ultimately what ends up doing,
he's going to bring that,
you know,
it's like just,
I like it.
Try to do,
not everyone's going to be the best artist.
Not everyone's going to be the best actor.
Not every.
It's like so when your dreams get crushed or you know,
it's like be fucking awesome at your job even if it's not what you like wanted
to do.
And then like,
I don't know,
I think about chefs a lot now because I'm friends with a lot of celebrity chefs.
That's not a fucking that you're serving.
You make food for people.
That's not a glamorous thing,
which like my friends like David Chang and board and it's becoming more glam
because they took a shitty job where it's like,
fuck,
I got to stand on my feet and where these weird clog shoes all day and all
these,
Eh,
this is too salty and take it back.
It's like a shitty job.
You're like a servant.
But they took that job and they made it glamorous.
They fucking brought their fucking rockstar passion energy to it.
And now it's like,
you know,
I went to a chef convention,
uh,
this thing,
mad symposium in Copenhagen and I,
I mean there's guys with like knife tattoos and weird facial piercings and I'm
like,
is this like a rockstar convention or something?
And so there are artists.
Well,
yeah,
and they brought that to that.
And so I'm just like,
be fucking dope at your job,
whatever it is.
I think being a chef is being an artist.
I really do.
I think it's cuisine is a form of art and the different flavors that you can
definitely in someone's mouth,
there's this,
there's an art to that.
Without it.
I really learned that from Bordain watching a show and the passion that he has
for it,
like eat,
it's contagious.
It makes you,
yeah,
guys like [inaudible] brought that to that brought to your attention.
And so now it's like you meet kids that are like,
I want to be a chef when I grow up.
And it's like that,
that really didn't exist before.
You know,
everybody has something that they're really into.
Some people are really into riding horses.
I couldn't give a fuck about riding horses.
Some people are really into,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Right?
So it's a matter of what your personality fits best with and trying to pursue
it.
One of the most insidious things where it happens to young kids is not just the
compromising early and falling into a slave
job.
It's being saddled with debt,
right?
Being saddled with debt right off the bat,
that it happens so fucking often,
man.
Right?
So often kids go to school and then they accrue fucking $300,000 in school debt
and then they get out and they're fucked.
They're slaying.
They almost did it to themselves.
Yeah.
Well,
like someone will tell them like,
look,
college is in four years now it's more like five to six years.
You're going to be like a quarter mill in the hole when you get out and we're
not going to teach you anything here that's going to teach you how to make
money.
You're just going to know a lot about psychology,
especially if you're doing something technologically paced by the time you get
out years later.
Yeah,
and a lot of these professors are like dinosaurs.
They're like teaching you some shit that's like irrelevant now.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that for sure.
And it's just also the idea of wanting to figure out what you want to do with
your life and having to choose at 18 right?
You're a baby when you're 18 years old,
you're a baby,
you're,
you've only been alive for 18 years.
That's enough.
It's not even anything is your first and your,
the last couple of years is the first year you've been able to make your own
decisions.
Right.
And all of a sudden you have to choose the course of your life.
Then you've got your parents harping,
I,
David,
you should be a Dr. David,
who should be a lawyer.
David,
you should do this.
You should do that for the,
for the immigrant experience a little bit hard.
I mean every,
well everyone who was an American as an immigrant,
so it's like that is that experience,
the guilt level for the Koreans.
It's like I escaped from North Korea for you to stick a gun in a girl's butt
hole and like,
you know,
they use that.
They're like the tanks and the fucking bombs.
I had to dodge for you to come here and do Hong Dynasty.
Like did your family come from North Korea?
No,
but I didn't say that.
That's more dramatic.
I'm sure someone,
no,
but you know,
my dad was the fucking crazy escape story.
My mom has it too.
It's like,
it's nuts,
you know?
And um,
since you brought up debt,
can I speak for it for one second?
Like,
but up debt,
being in debt or whatever.
So I used to,
I used to do this show a thumbs up.
I just did the fourth season a year ago.
It's still not out yet.
But what is it?
It's just me hitchhiking across America is still not out.
It's,
well,
it's three seasons of it are out on vice and then the fourth one is like still
being edited or whatever.
It's the whole premise of the show is hitchhike from once point a to point B.
Um,
and you can't spend money on any,
anything.
Like it's just to show,
Oh man,
I'd love to have your life.
I'd love to travel.
I'm like,
I've been hitchhiking since I was 15.
I've only almost got raped twice.
That's it.
That's the worst that's ever happened.
Oh Man.
Almost knock.
How close a finger in the blood doesn't count,
right?
No,
I'm kidding.
Or Am I,
uh,
so it's just,
you know,
it's,
it's weird now because I'm rich and I'm on the side of the road begging for a
ride.
Um,
but when I got to Detroit,
um,
basically,
well here,
let me just show you guys.
I'm going to there,
I'm gonna bring out visual restaurants.
Hadn't that bag.
This is a Harry Kim.
He's my partner on a,
on a thumbs up or show.
So you got a bag with his face on it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well I love him.
You met,
you had this made,
so here's $100,000.
This is a hundred thousand real dollars.
Yeah,
there's a hundred thousand real dollars.
I never felt $100,000 before.
Oh Shit.
It's Kinda heavy.
Yeah.
Damn fat bricks.
I like,
I like hip hop.
Uh,
Joe.
so what I like to gamble and when I got to Detroit,
I didn't realize there was an MGM there.
There's like MGM casino there.
And so in the middle of filming,
thumbs up,
season four,
you know,
I,
I won 10 grand at the casino like,
and what do I,
what do I need that for?
You know,
so I've,
I've never,
I've never been in Detroit before or I haven't been in Detroit and I don't know,
since I was 15,
you could buy Detroit for 10 grand and it looks horrible.
It's pretty bad.
And I've been to these third world countries,
people like,
Oh man,
look it like Bosnia.
And I'm like,
look at America,
it looks horrible.
And I couldn't believe,
I was so shocked by it because you've heard stories about it.
And I was like,
I got filled with so much emotion.
I was like,
you know,
I'm just gonna hide this money.
And I just like threw it and like I hit it around,
you know,
like in like shitty areas and just put up a tweet.
I said,
hey,
I just hit 10,000 in Detroit.
And it's like,
I heard about a guy doing that in San Francisco and he's like,
Hey,
if you find it,
tweet it.
And it's like this big social media experience.
I'm like,
I'm not doing a social media experience.
I'm just like,
Hey,
I'm fucking hiding money.
And then like I just walk around the block and I tell all the homeless people,
Hey,
I just like through like 10 grand and if you guys want to look for it,
you know,
and so that just give him the money.
Why make it a fucking game?
That's true.
I don't know.
Games are fun.
You don't,
people are like,
I don't want to play games.
I'm like,
I love playing.
Games are fun.
So anyways,
the people who found the money,
I'm sure it didn't tweet about it and they're like,
Eh,
the,
the backlash comes quickly.
You fucking piece of Shit fucking with poor people like that,
this and that.
I'm like,
what?
Because you didn't find the money,
you know,
so would it be fucking with people if you said that you hid the money and who
didn't?
That's what they're implying.
I'm like,
what?
Why would I do that?
That's dumb,
you know?
So I,
well I like fucking with people,
but whenever I do shit with money,
I just get,
you know,
just give it away.
I don't,
I don't want to fuck with,
it's like,
hey,
here's a hundred had to get away.
I'm like,
I'm not doing that.
So I'm a hoarder.
I don't know if you know that.
Yeah.
My,
my,
the House that I live in is actually half the size of this room and I've lived
there for 15 years and it's just,
people don't understand it cause they're like,
you could live in a like a fucking mansion and have your own island and
whatever.
And I'm like,
yeah,
but I don't care.
You know,
so I haven't gambled since like,
you know,
since I went to Rehab for gamble gambling and had my heart attack and all that
stuff,
when did this happen?
35 so three years ago now,
he went to Rehab for gambling.
I couldn't stop man.
And,
and,
and what they had done with the limits,
because in Vegas,
like the most,
you can bet on certain things.
It's like 25,000 a hand on blackjack or whatever is,
they raised it for me because they knew how much money I was worth and I could
bet a quarter million a hand on project.
So it could go pretty quickly.
I mean,
the shifts like,
oh,
I just won 10 million.
Oh,
I just lost everything.
You know,
how much did you lose?
This is where the mercury poisoning comes in.
Like the,
the height of my Vegas experience was like staying at the penthouse in every
single casino.
Like all the high roller casinos,
a Harem of whores in each one and just going downstairs and like winning 5
million here.
Going to like the next one,
going upstairs.
Fucking like 10 girls in a row,
going downstairs,
winning 10 grand.
What's the most you've ever paid a prostitute?
Uh,
the most money I ever paid a whore.
Um,
I like to say prostitute cause I'm classy.
Oh sorry.
Sorry.
Notice how I say that.
The,
the,
the most I ever offered a sex worker was,
um,
10 grand.
She wasn't,
this is a,
this is some vampire shit.
This is like when someone's not a sex worker.
Yeah.
It's like,
hey,
like,
not in.
The Asian guys don't want to fuck you at all.
Like I have no desire to fuck you and you're really crass.
You're a Douche bag your crude.
And I go,
okay.
So since,
since I'm not denying any of that,
um,
so this is real money.
Like this isn't a joke.
Like I'll,
you know,
I'm going to,
I'm going to turn you into a horror.
I'm sorry,
I'm going to turn you into a sex worker.
Did you say that to her?
Yeah,
it's actually all in this book.
Oh yeah.
This,
this book is all water colors and the text messages with women that people have
no idea that cause they don't believe me.
See my color chart here,
it tells you what you are stripper or a single mom,
like whatever.
Can I read one just to show him my favorite one?
Did it with text messages?
We converted or you did it I to I uh oh this one was a telephone because I met
her.
This is a,
this is a text message between me and a billionaire.
Okay.
I like,
at some point I just stopped selling my paintings.
I was like,
I just either give them to freedom,
my friends or you can look it up for free on Instagram or you can buy my books
that are cheap or you can go out and look at the murals.
I did like I didn't,
I'm not on this planet to make really expensive art for rich people.
You know,
so this guy like,
and you tell a rich guy,
he can't buy a painting.
He's like,
yeah,
how much?
So I write to him,
he goes,
I don't know how much higher I can go.
180,000 is my final offer.
I don't know what else you want.
No response for me.
Okay,
okay,
I get it.
You don't care about money,
but I saw you hit it off with my wife.
How much,
how much did that for a night with her and I,
right.
I don't know.
Let me get my,
let me get her lips off my Dick Right now and I'll ask her.
So it's like this is shit that happens that like people are like,
no it didn't.
And so he has,
he got,
is he playing,
I mean is this guy serious?
Is he playing around?
You know like when you get to that level of money,
like I know rich guys that like pay dudes to fuck their wives and like just,
it gets weird,
you know,
hey,
I was getting there.
Tell me about this girl,
this $10,000 girl.
So she's doesn't believe me.
And then I take a picture,
I go,
I'm holding 10 grand right now.
And she goes,
fuck you.
You piece of shit like you think you think like you can buy me.
I go,
all right,
fine.
Whatever.
I don't think much about it.
She calls me two months later and the text is months,
two months later and that whatever happens,
whatever happened in her life or whatever,
two months goes by.
I Dunno.
Month maybe,
I don't know.
I have no idea that the text is,
is the offer still good?
I don't even know who the girl is.
I go,
who is this and what?
What are you talking about?
She calls me and she goes,
you offering me 10 years and I go,
no,
it's five grand now you piece.
I go,
I offered you 10 grand when I was horniest.
Then I was like,
I was playing a game and I wanted it that bad.
I'm like,
I'm like no vagina.
The most any man should ever pay for a vagina is two grand,
like most the most like,
you know,
but what about that Robert Redford movie with Demi Moore?
They should,
they should remake it with the two grand.
It's like I played this game.
It's says dumb game,
but you know,
I've played with awesome people in our show.
It's like someone who's not a horror person who has a regular job.
Bartender fucking,
I don't know,
something where you make like you're,
you're middle class.
What does it cost for a person who's not a prostitute,
who is single,
who has a normal job to just go up to them and go,
I will pay any amount of money to fuck you.
Is it the Robert Redford movie isn't a million?
And like I go for normal chick,
like,
I don't know,
20 grand,
maybe 10 grants,
30 grand,
something like,
as long as they know that no one's going to find that and no one will ever find
out did it someone to shame.
Right.
And that's the real problem with the whole idea of prostitution is the shame.
And every girl I asked,
they're like,
I dunno,
five grand,
three grand,
two grand.
I'm like,
Whoa,
I shot it way too high.
Like all the guys always say something like 20 and up,
right?
All the girls that are,
maybe it's the women and all the guys.
If you want to fuck the guy.
No,
no,
no.
When I asked guys,
what do you think the number was now this girl,
when you said now it's five grand,
what'd she say?
Then she said,
go fuck yourself.
Then she didn't have no,
then she called me back and then she came and she fucked me and then she didn't
take the money and she left and I thought she'd forgotten.
I said,
hey,
you didn't take the money.
It's still on the thing.
She said,
go fuck yourself and then we have a weird and we still fuck now we have a weird
relationship.
Good kid giving out freebies basically attracted to you.
I don't know.
I'm sort of a strange,
this is the worst answer,
but when you say what's the most ever paid?
It's with my soul and time.
Like I mean money.
When money's no object for me,
it's when people wasting my fucking time and they play games with me and they
suck my life force out.
That's what cost me the most.
No,
I want to get into something with you because you were involved in this gigantic
fucking controversy,
right?
And knowing you,
I know you and I know the way you communicate and I know the way you fuck around
with things and the way you talk about things.
You told a story on your podcast DVD asa about getting a massage therapist to
give you a blow job,
right?
And by forcing her head on face,
face face,
fucking her face,
fuck.
And everybody decided that you were a rapist,
that you had raped her and that you know,
you,
you faced this massive amount of backlash online.
All right.
Well
of all like,
because I do the news like for vice or vice and to see like if I,
if I interview a Norwegian general or something and he says something,
we fact check it.
We fact check the fact and it's like,
oh,
okay.
And then it's like we're presenting ourselves as news people.
It has to be accurate now.
People who just like some,
I don't know,
like the TMZ,
Paris Hilton,
Perez Hilton type of shit where it's like we heard this and then they just,
it's all like,
this guy's a piece of shit.
And it was just all gossip rumor stuff.
I'm not even trying to defend myself.
Like I totally fucked up on that end.
My Shit,
your shit is live.
My Shit is not live.
Um,
when I record a show,
I record usually five to six hours,
three shows back to back because we're not around a lot.
And you really one a week.
Well yeah,
we did two a week for a year and a half.
And then it's like,
hey,
the show,
I don't know,
like I know the first time I came on your show and you're like,
I don't like to talk about my wife for my family,
this and that.
And like that's where you draw the line.
My thing is I don't have a line,
like I'll talk about anything and I noticed that,
um,
my,
my life,
I started to like lay in true artists forum,
be extremely self destructive.
Forget about like talking about heads of companies and this and that.
It's like,
wow,
I'm really like,
oh my God,
this girl that I just met won't fuck me.
Oh I heard you say horrible stuff about like this and that.
Like I'm throwing myself under the bus constantly,
you know,
with my own show.
And we'll you doing it to get a reaction when you were doing all this stuff.
Basically what happened was my friend who's a lawyer said,
dude,
you're getting into a lot of trouble.
And when I say so I'm like,
here's a show I don't have to do at all.
It's costing me money,
time,
headache.
There's like weird stalkers hanging out outside,
you know,
it's like it was getting bad.
Um,
it was ruining my life and,
and everyone's like,
why are you doing it?
And I'm like,
cause it gets,
it feels good because it's impulsive because I like it,
you know?
Um,
so he goes,
look,
there's a lot of people that you're talking about that,
that they don't want you to talk about them.
Right.
They have real lives.
They have real jobs.
I'd say almost every like celebrity we've had on our show is asked to take the
show down or have it ever did except for Joe.
Joe was cool.
Um,
but,
uh,
he said,
look,
if you want to tell a story about like,
let's say Michael Jordan,
I don't know Michael Jordan,
but like say you were friends with Michael Jordan,
you want to tell a story about Michael Jordan and it's not say a famous white
baseball player.
So then it's like still a famous person,
you know,
he's like changed the race if the point of the story isn't who it is and,
but what happened,
right.
And change the race changed the,
um,
uh,
when it happened and changed like as many details without fucking up your story,
you know?
And so it was our third show of the day and my show is like chaotic.
I mean,
you've been on and there's like six people talking over each other at the same
time.
And I was trying to tell the story and no one was opinion attention.
And I don't listen.
Like when this show ends,
do you listen to yourself?
No,
I never listened to myself.
And that was the one time where I was like,
man,
these guys aren't listening.
So I exaggerated a little eye every,
all the bad shit that happened to me.
I deserved it.
I never should have told the story the way I told it.
I should've never like whatever.
Okay,
yeah.
Anyways,
I'm like,
whatever.
I'm not a rapist.
And so it was like,
oh,
that's what all rapists,
they,
I'm not a fucking rapist.
Like I've never like,
and then people started bumping me in with Terry Richardson.
I'm like,
nobody came out of the woodwork because I don't fucking treat people like that,
you know?
And it's like,
oh,
he faced fucked her.
I'm like,
the number one thing,
because I have been in prison five times is everyone because of growing up with
like these movies,
American meat,
whatever.
Whenever I go to jail is,
I'm like,
I'm not black.
I'm not white.
I'm the minority in prison who someone's going to try to rape me,
you know?
So then I think then the,
would you rather get fucked in your mouth or your ass or you know,
like those kinds of questions and yeah,
I've been to prison five times.
No one's ever tried to,
I dunno,
really tried to fuck my ass or face,
fuck me,
but disappoint you a little bit.
I felt a little bit,
you know,
I'm like,
come on,
not a bad looking guy,
but the show ended and uh,
and my manager comes in and goes,
do you ever listen to your own show?
I go,
no.
He goes,
that was the worst sounding.
Like,
he goes,
I know you,
you,
you sort of exaggerated and told that story weird.
Like you should just cut that out.
I'm like,
well then I would be a hypocrite.
Just put it out and no one gives a shit anyways.
Then,
you know,
like all these blog,
gossiping bullshit and they blow it out of proportion.
And I'm like,
well,
the show that I created in the first place,
like what happened was I wouldn't the,
when all this Facebook shit happen,
I went on Howard stern where I talked for two hours unedited.
Right.
And it was live.
Then I went on Barbara Walters and she butchered my thing and just took out like
tidbits of pots.
Contact.
Yeah.
And I was like,
fuck this.
I'm going to have my own show where no one can ever fuck with me because it's
going to be from my perspective.
And what I did was I fucking shot myself.
I'm like the only,
I'm the only person ever fucking person in a sex scandal where there's no victim
except for myself.
And I did it to myself.
I'm like,
there's no fucking one coming forward.
They're like,
wait,
the feminist is like,
wait til this chick comes forward and we're going to all get behind her and pay
her legal fees because Dave's rich.
And I'm like,
no one's coming forward.
Like there's nobody there.
It's like,
like the girl likes me,
I face fuck her like every week now it's like,
it's like face fucking is not rape.
It's like,
ah,
it's like fun.
Like you know what happens when you don't want to face Facebook?
Somebody you bite their dick off.
That's what happens.
Like that can happen.
That is an option.
Um,
so like when you were doing it,
is it just,
you just get caught up in the moment and you just trying to be entertaining?
Are you trying to to just to be controversial and be exciting?
I just got,
I was really tired and this is like,
this is exactly what happened.
Everyone,
no one that I was losing control of the show and like,
look,
everyone always goes,
why don't you just do your own show?
You fucking talk forever.
Why?
Why don't you do show like,
you know,
Adam Corolla or Joe's where it's just like you and like one other person or two
other people.
Why do you have like 10 guys on your show?
You know?
And so I was just losing control of the show.
It was tired.
It was late and I was like,
I'm going to say something a little bit more exaggerated so that bill perk up
their ears,
which it did.
They're like,
oh,
and then look,
and then the shitstorm started and it's like,
I was like,
well,
who cares?
Like I didn't do it.
I didn't do anything from their point of view.
Of course,
the point of view of people that are listening to that and you know the,
the whole concept of rape culture or you're promoting the,
well,
can I just say during that whole thing,
Joe is like the,
like the only one of like my celebrity buddies that like call me and was like
just,
he was a good friend.
So thank you for that.
Well,
you're welcome.
You know,
first of all,
I don't know if you raped somebody,
but I don't think you ever would.
He just,
I can't,
I could be wrong.
Obviously it could be wrong,
but I listened to your explanation of it and I know what it's like when you're
doing a podcast because sometimes you just trying to be entertaining.
I seen people exaggerate stories.
I know,
I know.
I've been on podcasts before where people have told stories that I know what
really happened and they're trying to make it better by adding a little to it.
But the way you did it,
if you any crazy.
Yeah.
If you and me went through some crazy shit and like we were like,
let's talk about it without getting in trouble.
Then we have to change some details and dance around and turn into a rape
session.
But to the people that listen to it,
I kind of see their point,
oh,
when I went to 100% when I went back and heard it,
it sounds horrible.
Right?
That's why I was like,
everyone who like got down on me,
I'm sorry,
like I deserve like knowing who I am and then like hearing like that thing,
I was like,
whoa,
that sounds bad.
Like so,
you know,
but my,
my defense,
my delusional defense of like,
but I didn't do it.
It's like if I said anything,
it just sounds,
anytime anyone sounds tries to defend themselves,
it sounds horrible.
I was like,
whatever.
I mean,
I know,
I totally understand what you're saying.
So,
um,
and I understand it from a point of someone who does podcasts too,
that you can say things sometimes that you don't mean it even you just trying to
be fun or titillating or in your case trying to be really controversial to
change,
change the tone of the room.
You just fucked up.
You know,
Patrice O'Neal was talking about something once we was talking about people
trying to be funny that sometimes people say like really offensive things,
that they're trying to be funny and it fails and they're a horrible person and
he's like,
but if they said something that wasn't offensive and funny and it,
and it succeeded and made you laugh,
it's comes from the same place.
It comes from this place of trying to make something entertaining.
Well,
we say make mistakes when you're doing things live.
Look,
you've been on our show and then once I,
I,
I want,
I need to go back to the North Korea America thing.
It's like,
I know I'm not a murderer.
I know I'm not a racist.
So why can't I say like aids jokes or it's like,
I get it now.
It's like,
oh,
well you are,
you have a responsibility.
People will hear that and think,
you know,
it's like when I'm with asa and we're not on the air,
and we were just saying the worst shit to each other.
It's like,
who cares?
You're also dealing with Asa Akira,
who's like one of the most hardcore of hardcore porn stars,
right?
So like her tolerance level and that's what she thinks is funny and
controversial is so different.
Well,
that's what has happened is hanging out.
And I'm not blaming us.
It's like I have a lot of porn friends and I have a lot of this Yoshi,
like a lot of disturbed people.
And so when we fuck with each other,
you know,
and you know,
comedians and like,
like you start to forget that there's normal people out there,
but they don't know.
Yeah.
You're like,
oh well like that.
Like,
you know,
me and my friends when we get together horrible.
Like,
like this is,
I told you about Steve Lee,
Anne and bill.
Bill Poon doing the Macau brothers.
So Steve's the lead singer of my band now,
I started a band called Mochi with money mark from the Beastie boys.
Steve never gets laid,
he fucks a pocket pussy every night.
All right?
And so I say,
hey dude,
if,
if something happens with our band,
you're going to start,
you're the lead singer,
you're going to start getting late all the time.
And you put pussy way up on a pedestal.
Like he gets so distracted.
If a girl likes one of his photos on Instagram,
he's like,
Dave,
look at her.
And I go,
hey,
like you gotta you got to concentrate on like learning these lyrics.
Like,
like get into the shit.
So I said,
you know what,
I'm going to take you to Vegas and we're going to have an old,
old school.
Like when I was in the height of my gambling,
we have old school or g and you're going to fuck nonstop and you're going to
learn that pussy is,
it's just sex.
It's not like this,
you know?
And he's like,
I don't for that Dave.
So thumbs up,
I'll show you.
I'll show you a cool video after.
So we go to Vegas and he's getting his dick sucked by two women at the same time
going,
Dang,
this is amazing.
Oh my God,
this is so warm and wet.
This is like the best
feeling ever.
Like,
and it's,
it's uh,
it's,
he's having the best time and,
and he's like,
Oh wow,
I've never had a threesome before.
I go,
there's another one coming.
So he had like one,
three,
some after the next.
He's just like,
I'm on the bed just filming it for him cause I'm like,
I'm like,
dude,
you,
you'll want to watch this later.
I'm like,
every,
every time you think like,
oh,
like this girl,
whatever.
Like,
like,
just remember you getting one ball in her mouth,
one ball in this other chick's mouth.
And uh,
you ever see,
this is a little bit off topic,
but you ever see that Seinfeld where the guy converts to Judaism so he could
tell jokes.
So I'm sitting on the bed filming Steve,
get his Dick sucked by two women and one of them stops and she,
and he starts fucking one chick and she's like,
look,
it is,
but it's so cute.
I go,
yeah,
Steve's got a really cute bud.
And she goes,
should I stick my finger in it?
And I go,
yeah,
go for it.
And he goes,
no,
don't do it.
Exit only.
But he's still fucking,
the girl said,
she goes,
she spits a looking at his ass and I go,
I'm going to stick my finger in his ass.
So I stick my finger in his ass and I go,
can I start saying fat jokes?
Now I'm like,
I'm pretty much gay Yak.
Hey,
you can't say fag.
And I go,
but I'm,
I did something gay right now.
Um,
so I dunno.
It's like,
yeah,
your tolerance level in your,
your level of like what is acceptable?
Come back.
I tell people this shit.
And then we found out,
find out that bill who fucked like 30 hookers can't,
he's 53 he can't come.
I go,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I don't use my hands and I wear women's underwear and I use the tightness of the
band around my boner.
And I talked back and forth until I come and I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
So then we made another TV show that we haven't filmed yet,
which is,
I go,
wait,
so when you fuck hookers?
Yeah,
I go,
that doesn't feel good to you.
He goes,
no,
I go then white calm.
Then why don't you call me?
He goes,
well,
and cycle you're thing is psychological.
You,
you,
what is it?
He's like,
I got to go.
Is it something like where you feel like the girl doesn't deserve your calm or
something?
So I made a whole new TV show for him called girlfriend experience and I'm
sending him to Columbia and I paid a model like that.
Looks like Sophia Vergara Bill.
If you're listening like you know,
not the most attractive guy,
like a short,
like I'm very fat,
nerdy looking Asian guy with a girl.
Like basically I told the girl,
you can't ever talk about money.
You have to trick them and pretend like you're his girlfriend for 30 days and
then see if he finally come.
So it's like the whole TV show.
If you fuck 30 hookers and you don't basically,
sorry,
that's my life now.
So that feels normal.
So when I talk about this shit with you are my friends,
it's like whatever.
That's weird.
We just talked about Asian guy that works in,
in women's panties to come in and then you're like,
oh wait,
maybe this isn't polite dinner conversation.
Maybe like my world views a little bit skewed and it's a little,
you know,
it's like,
um,
you know,
I'm not the best person to bring to like a dinner party with wives and stuff,
like yeah,
that's a,
that's definitely not polite
dinner conversation.
Right.
So it's like,
I dunno.
And you've been on our show.
It's like when,
when you go in the room and the doors close and then everyone just starts
fucking did you just like,
you're like,
you forget that another world exists.
You know,
when everybody starts talking about crazy shit.
Yeah.
You sort of like get into that mode and it becomes acceptable.
Like if you're around people that never swear and someone walks in the room and
says fuck,
it's like,
oh right.
Oh my goodness.
Right.
But if you're around people that are constantly swearing,
you don't even,
it doesn't even like this conversation here,
but nothing,
nothing's registered.
Right.
And you'll save this fucking this or that means nothing.
But if the president said it in a speech,
you personally be like,
whoa,
he just said fuck.
And so I was like,
you get used to,
maybe I gave myself too much credit.
I'm like,
Hey,
I have,
I've developed my,
you know,
I've branded myself as a fucking crazy artist guy and I can do anything.
And I'm like,
oh,
I guess not.
You know,
it's like,
you know,
like when you tell someone you're an artist,
like it's sort of like free that you can do whatever.
Like I find out rape,
that's where I know you're victimized.
Found out.
Yeah.
Like you made a mistake.
My whole thing is like I'm around a lot,
you know,
and I'm not saying this at all to get sympathy,
but like I get raped all the time.
I like women grab and touch me and do shit to me that I don't want and it
doesn't count because I'm a guy and I'm not,
I'm not even please,
please.
I'm not saying it all because like I like it whether it's rape or not,
it's like,
yeah,
I got molested,
all this shit.
It's like,
how's it molesting you if you like it because I,
because I don't want it and then it's like,
I like that.
I don't,
Joe are we sit as a whole that we can't have conflicting emotions at the same
time.
I love and hate you at the same time.
Know when it starts I'm like,
I definitely don't want this chick to be touching me.
And then it's like,
then it feels good.
Well I'm a sick person,
I'm a sick demented person.
And what that was part of what you were talking about when you were talking
about this experience,
like you were talking about the fact that it might be kind of rapey was what got
you off and you were saying that again you're a brown,
a bunch of fucking perverts for also was trying to take it to the next level
also was like,
so you're a rapist and I was like,
yes,
I'm a rapist.
And it's like,
no,
I'm not a rapist.
But it's like I don't,
I know I'm not so I'm joking.
You kind of forget also that a lot of other people that don't understand your
sensibility,
you going to be listening to this.
Right,
exactly.
You assume that the people that get it,
I like,
like on my message board,
my message board,
it's like this ridiculous message board and some,
some of the subjects are just so like,
but everybody kind of understands the tone of the boards or they'll say
something really fucked up and if it was on any other message board,
people might like read it and go,
what the fuck did this guy just said?
But it became normal.
Well,
yeah,
I still am not there yet.
It's like when I have,
when I get new fans from like being on the boarding show,
or if I'm reporting the next cold war coming,
that's serious shit.
And then they come over,
they're like,
oh,
I liked this guy owner.
What else?
He's up to rape.
And they're like,
Whoa,
fuck,
uh,
you know,
so it's like,
I don't know,
but they'll figure it out eventually that sale.
I mean,
you still,
you,
you're still doing the same shit.
Can I say something
that it's like,
if someone's not a rape,
is it,
and it's like,
it's,
it's such a huge fucking thing to call someone that when they're not,
and it's like,
you're literally like ruining that guy's life.
But how would they know that you're not a rapist?
That's the problem.
They would assume that you are,
I saw people that I know call you a rapist,
and I was like,
oh,
this is a man.
Like you don't even know me.
It's like,
but they're basing it on what you said.
It's your fault.
It's,
we both agreed zero defense,
no fault.
From what I said,
it sounds horrible.
You know me mean you're like Dave,
just,
I know,
I know your whole thing,
right?
But your style of community and I know that Shell,
which is crazy.
I love your show.
I loved the Han Dynasty Shit.
I level is wacky shit you do because I really think you want to sit in the rape
stuff.
I really think it's important to have a guy like you out there just pushing the
boundaries.
I think what you said about Jackie Chan,
it's funny,
but it's fucking important because in,
in terms of like identifying and
communicating about racism,
right?
That's a real racist thing.
And for a person who's Asian,
that's gotta be kind of fucked up.
It is.
It is kind of fucked up.
And it's like I just,
Charlie Sheen out there,
it's banging hookers and it's like,
Yay,
Code Charlie.
But then you do it.
It's like,
oh,
Dave's creepy.
But it's,
it's the,
the people that like come at me the most Asian women,
they're mad at you.
They're mad at me and says,
your phone and white checks,
that's fine,
but you're all Asian all the time.
But this is what it's done on the grave.
It's like,
oh,
this day full of Shit,
this and this and this.
So like I said,
during the height of that,
like crazy Vegas era,
I would be going to Vegas all the time with like a hundred grand,
$1 million in like a pillowcase in my backpack.
It's much that looks like
this.
Went to Vegas with $1 million a year,
all the time.
All the time.
And so as the most money I've ever seen in my life,
by the way,
I've never seen $100,000 check this out.
Watch Joe.
I,
I'm cleaning my room for the first time in seven years since I lived in the,
my hoarders nest.
It's just,
it's just filthy.
I find a shoe box and I'm like,
Oh,
a hundred grand from the Vegas era.
And I go,
fuck,
you know,
critter,
I don't want to get into how much should he does for me.
But I sat here tearing them down about what a horrible personal trainer he does
shit that like,
I can't even talk about here.
That's like the,
he's the,
he's my,
I love him shovels hole.
So I just,
I just gave him this,
I was like,
you take this because you're the fucking man.
He's like,
I don't want you to dirty money.
I don't,
I don't want to get,
I'm not,
I'm not a whore.
Like I'm not going to get paid for the whatever.
So I was like,
let's do it for all the people that go,
if I was,
I know $100,000 in $1 million,
but it's like,
it's just money.
It's get,
get a kid out of debt.
And so all these people complaining,
well,
if I was rich or this and that,
or it's easy or because I did,
so this hundred grand cash like this,
I'm just going to give it to someone.
It's not like some weird like,
oh,
fill out this form and we half or when he's going to give it to you,
but you have to go around the United States and you've got to do all that.
Critter put all these clues in place and immediately they're like,
well,
we're not rich like you.
I go,
I've traveled around the United States for nothing and they're like,
oh well like we have lives,
we have jobs.
I go,
it's $100,000 that's why you would do it.
And so,
and with all the shit,
they're like,
we never even know if this guy is serious or not.
So I'm putting a hundred grand up in this critters cross country cash contest
scavenger hunt.
That's what it's called.
10 people are playing.
Only 10 10 people are playing.
I bet this more now.
Well,
yeah,
I mean I wanted to hitters cross country cash contest caught all the details are
at DVDs.
DVD a.com.
It's five CC critters,
cross country cash,
five C's.
Here's the problem with that.
Your DVD asa page.
Anybody can go there and just find no,
the contest is the only thing on the thing that you can't fuck with.
You can't fuck with that threat level.
You could do it right now.
You still to change a threat like yeah,
sure.
Why not?
I remember when that was like a big deal.
Like every dab haven't been talking about this lately with my friend.
My threat levels that what orange all the time man.
It's bad.
Do you remember when it was like that though?
Like everyday you just look at the news and the terrorist threat level that was
closer to like nine 11 and it was so ridiculous and it makes people like uneasy
and stuff.
That's the point of it.
And it's also a good thing for the news right here.
Threat levels at orange,
right?
Mother fuckers,
Goddamn Arabs.
Joe,
I love you.
I love you to be a fucking awesome guy man.
You're really,
you're a good dude.
I really,
it helps me to come on the show and talk to you about this stuff.
Cause I know like you go through a lot of the similar shit,
like everyone wanted to know like,
like why I'm so common the last three months it's because I took my showdown and
it's not for any reason that people think.
It's like literally like I was sitting at home one day and like there was a
glitch on our website and they're like,
oh the next episode can't count.
Go up tomorrow.
I'm like,
why?
He's like,
oh we got to call a guy and fix this thing.
And then I was just sitting there and thinking I was reading a comic book and I
was like,
I don't have to do this.
Like I don't have to do this.
And like I don't know what your fans are like,
but like my fans are horrible.
Like that's,
so that's my critters her today.
I knew if I showed this money,
like maybe someone's going to drive here right now.
So,
you know,
I think that you,
you're always going to have some horrible people that are out there.
First of all,
you have great fans.
Cause every time I do your show I go outside,
I go to supermarket,
they're like,
heard you won Joe.
And there's so nice.
Our fans are fucking great too.
But then there's like that handful of like if I talk about something then
they'll definitely go out of their way to like,
like if I try to like mask the girl that I'm talking about without giving away
your identity,
they'll put the clues together,
figure out who it is,
call her and be like,
hey,
Dave said horrible shit about you.
They're usually wrong and they just live to sabotage me.
Why do you think that is?
I honestly try to figure that out.
Like I don't watch a lot of television,
but like,
you know how there's like all this like reality TV,
the Kardashians and all this shit and the housewives and people were like,
I hate this show but I can't stop watching.
I really feel like there's people that hate me,
that watch everything I do.
I could be wrong about this.
And then like just,
I get excited and I am like,
cool,
I have a show where I could talk about anything.
I talk about it.
And then I find out,
like we did a couple episodes in big bear and I was like,
cool,
we're doing shows in big bear while we're doing the shows in big bear because we
said that someone went online,
found out the address of the thing,
blasted it on the line,
wrote the manager and said,
Hey,
there's a disgusting porn star and a fucking rapist artists they're doing any on
the landlord calls us.
And he's like,
Hey,
like what?
What's the like we're trying to have this,
like we spent million dollars building this like nice resort honeymoon,
big bear ranch and you guys are turning it into what it was this post,
the internet controversy or pre after,
after.
Um,
so I'm just like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Right?
Like you gotta assume that then people are looking at you as a target.
They're going after you.
Right.
And,
but I'm also like,
like I said,
I don't need to be put making painting this bright fucking bullseye on me all
the time.
So I was like,
you know what,
I'm just going to take a vacation now to take a break,
but we're back.
We're all going to do it again.
Well,
it's up there.
There's that,
there's are disgusting DVD.
Say Wikipedia page.
And I used to recording new episodes.
Yeah,
I mean,
well the thing is I never stopped.
I never stopped recording.
Like I never like we have like 30 50 episodes.
I don't even know the entire time.
You just recording them,
not releasing them.
W Yeah,
if someone shot me in the head today,
I'd have like,
like a year's worth of podcasts.
You can't stop this shit motherfucker.
You can't stop this shit DVD.
Say forever.
Fuck man.
People that are going to be very happy.
People were very bummed out on my website and my message board.
People were very bummed out that you took your show down.
Well,
I'm like,
I'm always like,
who gives a shit?
Like,
you know,
we'll give a shit.
But you got to understand,
okay,
as your friend this,
this,
this persona that you've created,
you who you are,
you,
your actual human existence where you are.
And then on top of that,
all the hyperbole and exaggeration and fun and chaos and all the stuff that
you're doing,
all the machine guns in buttholes and all this chaos,
you're automatically going to attract a certain amount of unsavory attention and
learned that,
no.
Well,
it's also plus people are fucking haters.
There's a lot of years out there and there's a lot of people be stronger.
They want to not like something they,
they're looking for something to distract them from the miserable existence that
they're caught up in or,
and there's also people that think,
hey,
this guy's a piece of shit.
Rapist.
I have a target now.
And then they go after you because of that.
Well,
how do you deal with it?
My dog done not a red piece of shit rapists.
Well,
I'm not saying you're a very nice person to say,
be nice.
I know you have crazy fans,
so it's to get crazy people.
You're always going to get a certain amount of them in.
Right.
I try.
One of the reasons why,
I mean I assume one of the reasons why the people that liked the show are so
nice.
My fans are so nice.
It's because I'm a nice person and you can also fuck them up by just,
it doesn't matter.
People could shoot you.
You know the people we say [inaudible] old go kick people's asses.
That doesn't last.
You know,
you pick KP,
people's acids,
they don't like that.
They shoot you,
they stab you,
they run you over the car.
Just be nice.
Like if you,
martial arts is supposed to be about developing your character,
about figuring out how you overcome difficult obstacles and how that makes you a
better person.
That's what it is for me.
Right?
So it's not about that,
but it's also about being confident so you don't have to worry about is many
people kicking your ass.
There's always going to be some people that can kick your ass no matter who you
are really.
Right.
Unless you're at the top of the fucking heat and then you're only at the top of
the heap for a certain amount of time.
Then when Cain Velasquez beat the fuck out of Brock Lesnar,
everybody was like,
Jesus Christ.
You can be a guy like Brock Lesnar somewhere out there.
This is bad ass dude with brown pride tattooed on his chest.
He just beats the shit out of you.
Always be someone that's always gonna be someone most likely.
But I think you put out a certain energy and you get back a certain energy.
That's the metaphor I said in high school I fought like almost every weekend
didn't win.
90% of them still did it.
So it's like that's,
if that's a says anything about you,
there's nothing.
I mean,
short of like putting a bullet in my head,
there's nothing like you,
you getting in that that black guy putting you in a thing and humiliating you.
It's like I've been embarrassed,
humiliated.
I've been called a rapist.
I've lost love and finance and anything bad you can do to me.
I've been in jail,
I've almost gotten raped.
You know,
like,
it's like there's nothing you can do to me that I haven't done worse to myself,
you know?
Did,
but you've grown from all this stuff,
right?
I think so.
Have you grown from this personal experience?
Does that make sense?
I think so.
The rapist experience
Vr,
the VR virtual rape is experienced.
Um,
yeah.
You know that putting that out there now,
even though it's an innocent look and you're trying to entertain,
look,
when I like the,
the standup thing that I threw up on Vimeo,
it's like the first time I tried it like,
um,
you could see I'm shaking,
I'm trying to find words like I broadcasting,
I don't know how many episodes are up now,
like 600 or something like,
and you've been on TV.
I like,
I,
I've been a quiet guy drawing werewolves my whole life and I've just started to
do this shit.
I'm trying to figure out who I am.
I'm trying to,
you know,
I'm,
I'm learning and I don't mind,
I don't mind people judging me as I learned.
And I know that's going to happen with the haters and stuff,
but it's like,
look,
if you want to hit on me,
go ahead.
I'm like,
I'm sorry if it didn't turn out exactly the way you want it.
I'm sorry if I offended you.
Actually I'm not,
I'm not sorry if I offended you,
but it's just like,
you know,
I'm learning,
I'm learning.
I have my heroes like stern and whoever growing up,
it's like there's a little bit of emulation,
but then there's also like,
I want to be my own person.
So I'm trying,
you know,
I'm trying to figure out my,
and in the meantime,
like,
yeah,
I'm falling,
I'm failing here.
So I hopefully I'm learning from this experience.
It was also the,
there's an,
I dunno if there's an art or a skill to being in the public eye and expressing
yourself because I have not mastered that yet.
The shit that we all do,
and I know,
you know,
you hang around with guys that I know,
like Bobby,
who's fucking crazy,
Bobby Lee's crazy.
And there's,
there's shit that Bobby and I have done just hanging out at the comedy store to
make each other laugh.
Well Bobby said like ridiculously dark fucked up shit and I'll,
how a laughing.
I know he's not being on it,
but if anybody else came along it didn't know Bobby and heard him say that it
can be misconstrued.
And when you're broadcasting it to the whole world,
you're inviting,
you're inviting a bunch of people who don't know you as a human or you know.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
I mean you,
if that,
what you just said is a commercial for my show.
It's like we say some fucking horrible shit and it's like if you're,
if you're part of the family,
if you're part of the whole,
like you,
you're in on it,
then you get it.
If you're just like,
oh,
I saw him on Hbo,
let me check them out.
And you're like,
what the fuck did I just hear right now?
You know,
you should hire someone to go over all the DVD ass as you do them.
And then at the end of the episode go,
what do you got for me?
Well,
you said your rave,
someone,
Oh,
I definitely didn't do that.
Let me explain.
I was bullshitting there.
Well,
you know,
you said you robbed gangsters and you fucked him in the ass with a Dildo.
Well,
I didn't write,
but I can't talk about,
I didn't,
I don't need to hire anyone DVD.
Say If,
if you,
uh,
if you go to Dva,
say.com you can,
or like listen to it on iTunes or whatever,
but if you want to watch it,
it's on that Vidmar site now.
Cause like,
I don't want to censor anything.
We broadcast from an insane,
insane asylum.
Now.
It's from a real incentives outside of the insane asylum.
And so it's like,
Hey,
guess what?
We're always,
I'm fucking crazy.
How do you get to an insane look?
Look at the thing right now.
Okay.
Hey,
big bucks gets you whatever you need for Wally.
Check it out.
Where,
where does it say it?
This,
this is a whole thing now.
It's all black techs.
Ever since the show started,
your entire website changed.
Um,
I'm looking for it.
Where,
what am I looking at?
I'm just hit like a,
so we're calling it all the old shows.
It's,
it's the new DVD ACA.
So it's like saga to,
and then if you just click on it,
you'll see what the inside of the,
this is a shit website,
buddy.
It's horrible.
Okay.
Saga to saga to chapter one,
the ranch part.
W Sardines,
chapter two,
sardines.
Here,
I'll show you what it looks like.
Um,
but what are we looking for here?
Oh yeah.
Just play it off of youtube or Vimeo or whatever.
I'll show you the,
they're all inside of the insane probably crashing right now because all the
people going to that,
that's probably what's happening.
You probably got thousands of people visiting it right now.
Yeah.
I mean we put it up on youtube,
but it's censored and then we have it on video.
Me uncensored the episode two.
Right now there's a chick with like 34 g's,
or I don't know,
the biggest real tits I've ever seen in my life.
So a lot of people watching them,
they kept flopping out.
Yeah.
That's what's going on.
Um,
so how did you get you,
so you paid them to let you get into this?
I said,
look man.
Instead of like you said like,
oh that's,
that definitely crossed my mind.
I was like,
I'm just going to hire someone.
We're not live.
Right.
We're delusional.
We say dark shit at the end of that episode have like a lawyer go,
hey that you guys went too far.
And I'm like,
good.
Like that always makes me feel good.
Like,
you know,
I'm 40 I'm 38 years old.
I just started a punk band with Steve Lee and whatever.
My Dad heard it and he's like,
I've never been more embarrassed of you in my head cause it,
cause I have a Korean song where I was like [inaudible] it's like you want to
eat my farts,
you want eat my part?
And he's like,
you're a grown man.
You're a grown man and you just didn't like that.
His soul disgraceful to my country.
You're my son.
And he's like,
I'm begging you as you're,
I'm a fucking grown man.
He's like,
I'm begging you as your father.
Take that song down.
And I'm like,
yes,
I did something right.
You know,
it's like,
so instead of having a guy paid to be like,
take this episode down or edit this thing,
I'm like,
let's just broadcast live from a fucking insane asylum.
I don't think that's a real disclaimer though.
Come on the show.
I know.
It's not Joe 51 50 right?
Somebody have one of your employees just go over everything with a fine tooth
comb and then apologize at the end of every episode.
I just do everything as it as if one of these nut jobs is going to kill me one
day.
And she said the stack,
the podcasts that show shows,
this is all the,
the negative nut jobs are all post this,
right?
No,
I mean this is,
I mean,
I've had critter for for a few years now,
right.
But I mean,
the negative nutjobs the escalator.
I've,
I've had haters in my entire life.
You know,
people look at you like you're not just a talented artist.
You're talented artists that got some crazy break where you you,
but let's traded the Facebook offices.
He gave you a shitload.
I'm not gonna deny that the Facebook thing was a crazy break,
but I've made millions of dollars in like everything I've ever wanted to do.
And so it's like,
did I get a crazy break over and over again or did I just bust my ass?
And like you don't just fucking go for it.
You know you've been very successful end,
right?
You've got a crazy break.
Oh yeah.
I've been very successful and that,
and then so when anything happens they're like,
oh well,
like I said,
the way I started the show,
oh well he's rich.
I'm like,
well what about my entire life?
Up until then,
like was that a to marginalized people love to find some way where you're not
better than that.
The difference with the Facebook thing in my life before was nobody knew how
much money I had.
So when they went to my hoarder's house,
like I had millions already.
I already sold out a million dollar art show in London.
I had millions from gambling.
And like,
but nobody knew and I was like,
so I can still like that's the best.
It's the best Combo.
You get to live a normal life,
but you're fucking Richard Shit.
And then so you were rich before the Facebook shit.
Even when I didn't have hundreds of millions,
but I had a few million and I was like,
cool,
that's more than I ever thought I would make.
I'm selling paintings for a couple of hundred grand,
like it was awesome.
I go to Vegas and went a hundred grand.
It was like,
it was a very good life.
But now it's like,
you know,
if I go public now it's like gimme my email right now.
It's Jimmy money.
Give me money,
give me money.
Do you ever get people money?
No.
Never.
I hide it.
I didn't.
Well yeah,
I have all my $100,000 I'm going to give away,
but they don't.
I have to.
I'm making you work a little bit for it.
The clues,
the fucking clues.
Recruiters cash contest or like the dumbest like easiest clues ever.
I was like,
I want to make it all cryptic like the game and make it super hard.
And I was like,
no,
I'm literally forced feeding you the answers.
Like,
well,
what if more than one person finds it?
We have a whole thing.
It's like,
first of all,
everyone thinks I'm hiding cash.
I'm like,
I already learned from the Detroit thing.
I'm not hiding cash.
I'm just going to give it to you.
I'm hiding clues,
which is a red dot.
That critter spray painted at nearby the,
the place you go there,
you take a selfie of yourself in front of the clue with uh,
uh,
a current newspaper.
And then the first 10 people,
they get the points and at the end,
whoever has the most points.
And right now,
like I said,
there's only like 10 people playing and it's like the points are scattered.
So it's like anyone's game.
And I'm going to announce the winner on Halloween.
And then on November 2nd,
I'm just going to,
like on November 2nd,
November 2nd,
two years ago,
this is what happened.
I went,
you ever do an Ama on reddit?
Yes.
So I didn't even know what reddit was.
And everyone's like,
it's the front page of the Internet.
It's so I go,
okay,
so what does that mean?
And they were like,
you up vote.
And I,
and I learned what read it was.
So I said,
I'm going to do an Ama.
I'm like,
hey everyone,
I'm David Choe.
I'm an artist.
They used to be a thief.
I'm a gambler.
I want all this Facebook money that Dah,
Dah,
asks me anything.
I answered everyone's questions for 24 hours straight with live video response
with a cast of 200 of my friends and actors in midgets and porn stars and chefs.
And everyone I knew.
And everyone was like,
what just happened?
It would be a kid like,
hey Dave,
what's your favorite place to eat?
I Dunno,
let me ask Anthony Bordain.
And he'd be like,
what the fuck?
I and I,
so they knew that it was live.
I go right,
I dunno,
uh,
Dick face three,
seven to like,
and they were like,
oh my God,
he's talking to me.
You know?
So the next day,
like people started going,
fuck,
did you see this mother fucker blew up the Internet yesterday?
Everything got taken down.
Everything on Youtube,
everything on Vimeo,
everything on live wire,
everything on red tube.
Like we,
we put shit everywhere.
Like reinfected the whole Internet for like 24 hours.
It got taken down.
Why?
Um,
I don't know.
It was just like tits ass,
but like,
I dunno like,
but I rent red tube is like a porn site.
Yeah.
So we put up the more racier shit there.
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's haters over there,
but it's like,
and then they,
for like two years,
they made my name unsearchable on Vimeo.
Like if you typed in my name,
like any like art video or anything I've done.
So I was like,
I started getting paranoid and whatever.
So then that's why I love like [inaudible] whatever.
Like I sound like I'm doing a huge commercial for them,
but like I love them because you could do whatever I want.
So this year I'm going to do a fucking live podcast.
That midnight starting November 2nd for three hours.
Then I'm going to go on a reddit and I'm going to answer everyone's questions.
Same style with like hundreds of my friends have actors,
fucking famous people,
support stars,
everything for 14 hours straight.
Then I'm going to fucking have us live event where my band plays and we're going
to fucking have a huge party.
And then at midnight I'm going to fucking,
uh,
or close to midnight.
Like at nine I'll do another three hour live podcasts and then I'm going to give
this fucking money to somebody.
So 24 hours straight,
no sleeping.
I'm going to need red bull or some shit that
you should come by.
Yeah.
What day is it going to be?
November 2nd I'm going to be,
uh,
we'll talk.
It's okay.
I'm,
I might be able to do that.
Yeah.
Come by for like an hour or something.
That sounds crazy.
Yeah.
It'll,
it'll be fun.
It sounds like chaos.
Yeah.
I'm like,
I'll,
I'll like,
I'll answer anyone's question.
You know,
like on the,
the reddit thing,
they ask like crazy questions and then like if you ignore them,
they just up voted.
So it's like the,
the number one question or something.
Right,
right,
right.
I Dunno,
it's,
but once again,
don't have to do it.
Like the pain,
like the torture,
but you enjoy all the chaos.
You definitely enjoy it.
I live in it.
I live in,
yeah,
that's,
I think that's why you live in a tiny little place.
He didn't move to some suburban neighborhood in Beverly Hills and set up shop
and some nice,
you know,
have a manicured lawn.
You live like a crazy person.
It's manufactured misery,
you know,
the whole lot miserable.
You're not miserable.
It's miserable.
In what way?
It's,
it's smells so bad in there.
There's,
there's cockroaches,
ants.
But why,
why do that then?
Because you know,
you and me,
we could talk about like,
oh,
you should eat kale and this and that.
But it's like,
I know at the end of the day what I'm really going to do.
And so if I sit here and go,
hey Dave,
forget all this fucking bullshit.
You've talked up until now,
your podcasts,
TV bullshit.
You're an artist.
Okay,
so let's talk real talk about you being an artist.
How much have you actually painted in the last 10 years?
Not that much.
Okay.
Let's look at your entire life.
When have you painted the most?
When I was in jail in Japan,
when I was in a cold,
miserable place in China with no Internet,
no cell service.
So the,
the,
the combining factors of all these places is that it was always cold,
no internet and no cell service and no one else around.
So isolation,
cold and miserable and just that's what it takes now because I,
I am easily distracted,
addictive person so I can't,
and I do have a lot of options for pussy that I never had before.
I do have all these things and it's why do Joe's cross crosshatching of a
werewolf would like,
that takes a long time and I have it in my head,
oh man,
I want to paint this thing.
There's going to be a million little people and they get this crazy tripped out
idea.
It's going to take me like a week to draw that the way I want to draw it.
And then there's a playboy model that wants to suck,
might left ball and a pen house model that wants a sec,
my right ball.
And I'm like,
hmm.
Tough decision.
It's like wait,
that's what you know,
drawing my whole life was the only thing that brought me attention.
And now I have everyone's attention so let me fuck the whole world.
But isn't it?
It's like,
you know,
so you were talking earlier about your favorite thing is to create,
but there's a,
there's a self destruct thing that distracts you.
Okay,
let me,
let me backtrack.
Let me backtrack.
My favorite thing is creating and pussy.
So,
and let me,
and let me just ask you this Joe,
cause cause you're in it,
you're a comedian like,
like the whole white Wa like is the great art always come from misery.
It's like Jim Carrey,
Eddie Murray like do you have to be miserable?
You don't,
I believe you can make really good art if you're well adjusted and you're happy
and whatever.
But I'm talking about the great shit that transcends time and whatever those
people are suicidal,
miserable fucks.
And then speaking just for me,
because I know my best stuff always came from rejection,
hatred,
getting dumped,
living in miserable conditions.
There's nothing about living
in a 20 story like our 20 bedroom fucking mansion in Beverly Hills with pools in
playboy models hanging around.
That makes me want to create,
that makes me want to find getting your ball sack by playboy playmates.
It's still the most amazing paradise ever.
It's not staying in suites and Vegas and bang a $10,000 hookers.
You talking girls in the fucking you that never was sex workers,
sex,
sex worker side.
I didn't say horror at least.
Uh,
I,
I'm not trying to change your opinion.
Right?
But what I'm trying to say is you,
you love a lot of different things,
but you definitely have a self destructive streak.
But I don't,
when I was a kid and I was doing standup when I first started doing standup,
one of the things that I thought is,
man,
I don't ever want to get enlightened,
right?
Because if I get enlightened,
it's gonna fuck up my comedy.
Oh,
where's my comedy was always my favorite comedy was always like Sam Kennison and
Richard Pryor.
Troubled people are dirty people.
And I was always thinking like,
man,
you can never like achieve a certain amount of enlightenment because then you'll
never be able to do like the great comedy.
But I don't,
I think that's a trap.
Well,
check this out.
Like
I'm at my,
I'm at my warehouse,
we're in the wintertime,
it's freezing and I'll be painting.
And I,
and I remember thinking like,
wow,
it's two in the morning.
I'm miserable.
Oh Wow.
I have a heated fireplace.
A woman just playing with their vagina,
waiting for me to go in there in a beautiful house in Beverly Hills.
Oh,
I'm going to call it quits for tonight.
Now I'm there still painting.
And I'm like,
wow,
it's two in the morning.
I'm miserable.
And guess what?
My house in Korea town still miserable.
I'm just going to keep painting,
you know,
so that to know that that comfort,
like I say it all the time,
comfort is the killer of creativity.
Like to know that that's there.
Like it's not that I can't paint something good,
like something good is still being painted,
but it's not going to have the level of intensity of like it know,
being completely miserable and awesome.
Awesome.
Set.
Exactly the same thing you said right now.
She's like,
people try to make me feel bad for being a porn star.
I love fucking,
I love sex and that I've offered her,
I was like,
you know,
cause we have dark spots in our past.
Like I think there's a huge age gap where I don't remember where I'm like,
is that why I'm so fucked up?
Did I get raped or molested or whatever?
And she has the same thing.
So I,
I,
I go do lots of,
uh,
rich white people,
kind of enlightening,
you know,
wellness camps and shit like that where I'm always the only Asian guy in the
youngest guy there.
And I said to her,
I was like,
hey,
if you ever want to do that stuff,
I'll off,
you know,
I'll pay for your therapy and this and that.
And she's like,
I don't want to go and then learn something and become enlightened and then find
out that I actually hate myself in hate porn.
So she's enjoying her life.
She's enjoying her life right now.
Well,
people are very adaptive,
man.
Right?
We're very malleable and we change to our environments and you can,
you can become comfortable and happy and a lot of different weird circumstances.
And if you find a good state,
a lot of times people like this is,
I'm good.
I don't need no enlightenment.
I don't need,
I don't even know consciousness expanding.
I'm good right here.
Well,
I'll tell you right now,
like I'm this,
this a lot of people is like really discipline.
My friends and people close to me.
Like they're like,
oh well so sad and there I only fuck hookers now.
Like I don't,
like I've given up,
like,
I don't even want to say given up because I am adaptive in this could,
what I'm telling you right now could change tomorrow.
But as of right now,
I am working on animation TV shows,
my podcast painting,
working on my next book.
It's like,
there's no time in there for a real relationship for kids I can afford.
Like when you say,
why don't you just buy the best trainer,
the best nutritionist?
I go,
guess what?
I'm paying for the best pussy.
Like,
oh,
well you got to pay for it.
I go,
yeah,
I'm rich.
Yeah,
but they don't love you.
I go,
you could've fooled me the way these women said,
my Dick,
like the woman,
the woman who sucks my Dick,
like that's in love with me,
that wants to have my children like you when you give a woman fucking $2,000 and
she needs it and she knows if she sucks it really good that there's 2000 bucks
coming the next week.
She's sucking it like she's in love with you.
Like it's like that Dick is like her lifeline and it's feels pretty good.
And guess what?
And you've heard this before,
you're not paying them for that and you're paying them to leave.
So I get my dick sucked amazingly.
Like the chick is in her honeymoon phase like this,
like the fucking veins on my Dick,
or like a lifeline UV into her system.
Then she leaves and I spend all night writing,
drawing,
creating.
There's no like you were up all night.
You didn't call,
you didn't check in when you need to take me out.
And I'm like,
I am fucking so much right now.
Still fulfilling my,
my sexual needs,
sexual needs.
And then at the end of the night,
I cap it off with another bull job from a different drug.
It's like,
I'm,
I'm sorry if that upsets you.
If you're like,
oh,
well,
and it's the women,
they get upset,
they go,
I don't see anything wrong with what you're doing.
This is why,
first of all,
I don't either.
Totally voluntary.
Everybody's voluntary.
No,
no one's doing anything against their will.
They want the money.
You want to get your Dick sucked.
It's an awesome exchange.
Yeah.
You know,
I have a real problem with prostitution being illegal and this is coming from a
guy was daughters,
but I don't want my daughters to be prostitutes,
but I also don't want them working at fucking Denny's.
I don't,
I don't want them.
But working as a garbage people.
Well,
like I said,
the women I'm fucking aren't like,
I mean they're sex workers.
They're not like hookers I find on the street.
Or like I go online,
they're just people.
I know that I've offered them money.
Oh,
so there's like created,
I created them.
Wow.
We only work for you.
Well who knows?
Maybe.
Maybe I lit something up inside.
That's a great gig though few,
I mean,
look,
there's a friend that I'm paying you money to go get up.
Go like get away from me.
Yeah,
I really like you.
You know,
it's not just like where's the money and looking at the clock,
it's like,
I like you.
We had a good time,
uses money,
go to real estate school or whatever you're going to do.
But I need my time now.
That's what I'm paying for as a rich guy.
I value my time.
And that's why when you said earlier,
what's the most you've ever paid?
It's like when I do fall in love and catch feelings,
the worst STD you can catch,
it's like a,
it's like,
oh fuck,
I just wasted three months with the bitch that just fucked with my shit and like
is like trying to like play games with you,
me and fuck me over.
And it's like,
can happen,
right?
Yeah.
It can happen.
It can really happen and it can really fuck you up if you get involved with
someone who's manipulative,
who wants to control,
and I live in La,
dude,
I live in La,
you know,
and you've got money,
so you're a target.
I look Joe,
I feel like a catch.
I feel like I'm a soldier and I'm like in a war and I'm like,
Chris Rock has this joke,
right?
He's like,
you don't wanna be the first anything.
You don't want to be the first black president.
You don't wanna be the first back black baseball player.
He's like,
I'm butchering his joke right now.
But he's like,
do you want to be Jackie Robinson?
Nigger,
nigger this or you want to be dealt with Darryl strawberry,
coke,
blonde whores.
So like when I'm sitting here going,
hmm,
who was the only Asian guy that fuck the white chick on TV?
It's like one Guy Stephen you and it's like,
we're like sort of the first everything,
you know.
So it's a little bit stressful.
I'd rather be,
I'd rather like,
I'd rather be like 10 other weird,
wacky Asian guys and then like,
you know,
and Jackie Chan doesn't count.
I'd rather be like number 10 or 20 down the list,
you know,
like I don't want to be the guy in the forefront,
but guess what?
I'm not complaining at all.
I am complaining,
but I'm here.
I'm going to do my job and,
and I'm going to do it as best I can.
You know,
it's like I had to armchair psychoanalyze you.
I would say that you spend a lot of time conflicting with other people's
expectations and everything is very conflicted.
But
why?
Because you seem so free when you do your own thing.
But now this is the question,
right?
Is part of what makes you enjoy your life.
The fact that you reject these other people's expectations and their,
their definitions of you and you get to live free on your own end.
You're proving that you're successful,
you're creating great art,
you're having fun.
You're podcast is well received here.
You're getting all this attention.
You're David motherfucking show on top of the fact that all these people want
you,
your dad's calling you,
you're embarrassing our country.
You're fucking everything up.
Girls are mad at you.
You're like fucking hookers.
You're a piece I shed.
And meanwhile you're creating all this great art and you're living in chaos and
squalor.
You've got George Constanza,
I'm the guy,
not that guy.
David fucking show.
Um,
I,
this is,
you're going to laugh.
So recently I was having sex with this girl that has a lot of lines on her
hands,
like lines,
like not wrinkles,
but a lot of these lines.
So I said,
hey,
that's like,
like a lot,
like hundreds of unusual,
unusual.
So I said,
hey,
you've ever been to a palm reader?
So she said No.
So I said,
let's go to palm earnest.
So we went to the palm reader and I was like,
fuck,
I'll get my palm read too.
And she goes,
what are you,
I go,
I'm lefthanded.
She goes,
let me see your right hand first.
And so I flipped my hand over and she goes,
wow,
very enlightened internally inside,
like not much bothers you.
Very evolved like,
and I go,
okay.
And she goes to flip over your left hand,
Shia,
whoa.
Externally you fucking complain about everything and you whine and you bitch and
your mouth is very blunt and you get in a lot,
a lot of trouble.
And it's like I didn't grow up around Koreans.
I grew up around Jews.
So that whole like Larry David humor,
like the whole woody Allen Shit.
That's what I grew up around.
So yeah,
I can shit sit here and like fucking complain about everything,
but at the end of the day,
you're right,
it doesn't,
it doesn't fucking bother me.
I am very free.
I can just in one second say fuck this podcast and just quit it.
Like,
ah,
but I'm saying is I think part of what makes you happy is this battle.
Definitely.
Well that's just being Korean.
I mean there's nothing I could do about that.
Korean makes you want to a fighting chance things.
I
talked to Bordain about this on the show.
It's like they probably have it in every culture,
their own version of it.
But in Korea it's called Han and it's like,
it's like genetic.
It's like you're just like,
I have a friend who has adopted a Korean son and he has his own kid and he goes,
my normal kid is just,
you know,
cause he's rich and he's like,
he all my kids have everything they could ever want,
but this Korean one,
he just wakes up with a scowl on his face every morning.
I go,
yeah,
welcome to fucking Korea dude.
Like it's like you're just like David Chang.
He's the genetics.
He's one of my best friends.
He's like my twin brother.
And he,
he does like with cooking what I do with art,
like just fucking goes at it and he's very successful.
He's like on the cover of time.
And all these magazines and the best chef in the world and all this shit.
And when I hang out with them,
I mean he makes me look like it's just piss and vinegar,
like fucking her.
I go,
why
are you so angry?
I said,
I'm like,
you talking to me right now?
And he's like,
come on dude.
It's like all the keep GNR bloat or whatever.
But it's Korea is a small island or thought Ireland's a small country that's
been invaded by Japanese and fucking Chinese and everyone's always trying to
take over Korea.
So it's like almost like a evolution,
like builtin hate system of just being born like right,
right.
Took one day.
Workers,
man,
hard work.
It's like,
I don't know that there's a lot of similarities between Jews and Koreans.
I think on that end know I grew up with a lot of Koreans.
Yes.
So you know what I'm talking about environment,
you know what I'm talking about right now.
I mean I was,
I was around Koreans constantly.
They're loud.
You know.
The other thing about him is I've never met more people like as a group that are
more dedicated to hard work and like if you don't work hard,
if you're not miserable from working hard all the time.
Right.
He felt like a piece of shit.
Right?
Like I had a friend,
he was on the national,
my friend junk,
sick,
junk.
Sick Chang.
Yeah.
He was a,
he was a national taekwondo champion and at the same time he was going through
his fucking residency,
medical residency.
So this guy was always tired.
This is how I would see him like this.
Always tired.
And then he was just fucking workout really all for it and then be exhausted.
He would be at school and he was training so he would like be studying all day
and then he would run upstairs.
You run up the flight of stairs at the university.
He was constantly tired,
constantly miserable.
But he felt like if he didn't live like that right.
And I have to be happy,
that's in me,
that's in my blood.
And,
and so let me take it straight down to comedy and let me get racist for a
second.
I mean,
people ask,
I'm sure they ask you,
who's your favorite comedian?
I'm like,
okay,
forget specifics.
Who's your favorite comedian?
Blacks.
Jews and Koreans.
Koreans.
What?
Koreans?
Well,
it's like Bobby Lee.
Like,
okay.
So if I take it just to Asians,
there's not like Chinese comedian.
I mean there are,
right.
But there's no Japanese big.
It's like all the big car.
Funny Comedians that are successful in America are Bobby Lee,
Doctor Ken Jong.
Like they're all,
they're all crying,
you know?
But I think it's like this persecution.
Yeah.
Why?
Why is so Japanese big comedians?
I mean if I can't think of one right now or why aren't there huge Chinese and
why or why are there so many Jewish comedians?
It's just in here long persecution.
This torment part of the culture.
This why is Howard stern miserable?
Why is Jerry Seinfeld miserable?
Why is Larry David miserable?
There's so rich.
You have nothing to complain about your billionaire.
You have y.
And that's like sort of like what you're asking me right now.
I don't know why I'm so angry.
It's just there,
but it's like,
it's just like,
I don't know how to define like,
I don't know why Jews are so funny.
I don't know why Koreans are so funny.
I don't know why blacks were so funny,
but what did they have in common?
Persecution.
Persecution,
misery and don't you think though that like as Japanese and Chinese as
generations
go on and they become more assimilated,
especially because of the Internet,
you're going to see more and more Chinese comedians,
more Japanese comedians that things along those lines.
Don't you think like as they become more entrenched in the art form?
Yeah,
maybe.
Who knows?
I don't know.
Did you could be a comic and I'm not bullshitting you laugh.
I love that.
I love it.
Called you.
After I saw that video,
I'm like,
dude,
that shit is really funny.
Thanks Joe.
I appreciate it.
That's your first time on stage with those notes that you had on a table you
wanted to talk about.
I doubled.
My whole thing is always,
you know,
for me that's horrifying because you know,
in the same way comedy solitary,
you're not up there with anyone unless you're like smothers brothers and your
comedy duo or something.
But it's like,
I didn't want to have an act like,
like when I come here,
like it's like,
I was like,
I just wanted to make everyone sure that I've actually given this away,
this money and that's all I'm like.
And then everything else I'm like,
we'll just riff.
Right?
It's like you can just,
you know,
I had,
so I was like,
I want to go up there with no act.
And then like I started like writing stuff down,
but it's,
whenever I write stuff,
it just ends up being like dicks.
He's been drawing the whole time we've been on this pie cross crosshatching the
ball.
There's a dick with comscore,
it and out of it,
this is the whole time he's been on his podcast,
he's been drawn.
So in the auction,
that piece off,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you see the uh,
the closeup of me doing the comedy special and it looks like I wrote some flash
cards,
they're all just drawings of Dicks,
like on the side,
it's just so that's all that that was.
Yeah.
And so I'm like,
I'm like,
when I see the black guys on the corner,
like hit on every single girl,
they're like,
Hey,
what's up?
And I'm like,
dude,
does that really work?
And they're like,
no.
But the one time it works out of a hundred,
it's worth it,
you know?
So when,
when,
when I was,
you know,
thinking about doing stand up or whatever,
I'm like,
okay,
so if I get,
if I bomb like the worst,
like bill,
you suck and they throw oranges or I don't know what they throw tomatoes,
tomatoes,
do they really do that?
I don't know her.
It's like,
okay,
so what,
like hey,
I already like pain.
Like,
you know,
it's like win win for me.
If I'm humiliated,
I'm like,
oh,
I tried it,
I sucked.
So I just was like,
fuck it.
I'm going to go for it.
And I,
I,
I was like,
I don't want to act.
I know I'm talking to college students,
so I'll try to like stay on college topics and how dumb it is.
But um,
yeah.
Who did that with you?
What do you mean is just you,
it was just you.
Yeah,
it was just me who organized that show.
Um,
so I get asked to colleges to talk about like art and whatever.
Right.
And I,
and I never do it.
I used to do it a long time ago and then it's like,
you know,
someone's like,
David's very like almost like motivational Tony Robbins kind of speaking kind of
shit.
And I was like,
like some Tom who shit be like,
main,
you'll make my money.
And um,
you know,
cause I know how to make money.
Like if,
if you stripped away everything took all my money,
I could go out and figure out how to make money again.
Like,
it's not like I'm very confident with that.
So I'll,
you know,
when they approached me,
they were like,
hey,
we would like to speak,
you know,
you'd like to speak at,
it's very prestigious.
Bill Clinton,
Dave Chappelle,
Michael Moore,
all these people did it.
And I was like,
well,
what do you want me to do?
And they're like,
talk about whatever you want.
I go,
well then I'm going to try stand up.
And they're like,
oh,
we didn't know you were a comedian.
I go,
I'm not.
And they go,
ah,
this is awkward.
And I go,
well,
what do you mean?
Like you're going to tell jokes and stuff?
And I was like,
yeah,
sure.
And they're like,
um,
yeah.
All right,
cool.
So you'd wear a nice red suit.
Yeah.
And since I did that,
I did it five more times.
And it's like,
it's so fun.
I can't,
did you do it in Hawaii with Bobby?
And I did it in Hawaii.
He that fucking asshole.
So he's like,
before,
before the show,
he's like,
David,
I can't,
you're like a weird Warhol,
like artsy fucking faggy dude,
I get it.
But you don't speak the language of comedy.
You don't speak like I need a real,
I need a real opener,
Dave,
that you and my fucking brother touching each other's dick.
He's like,
you don't,
I need the audience to get ready for when I get on stage.
Like I don't want you up there doing some weird artsy fucking fake rape shit or
whatever.
Like I need a real comedian and I go,
fuck you dude.
Fuck you.
You're such a piece of shit.
And he goes,
oh you know it was last minute.
He couldn't find anyone and I said,
hey fuck face.
Guess what?
I've seen your standup 10 times.
I have your act memorized.
I'm going to do your exact act before you got to go.
What the fuck are you going to do about it?
And his face changes.
It goes because I thought he thought that's me being delusional.
I thought he thought it would be funny.
He's like,
don't do that Dave.
I go,
he goes,
that's like me going to your like if I had an art show or if you had an art show
and I had like the counterfeit of that right next door.
I'm like,
cool.
Then I would just paint something else like you as a real comedian,
if I just sabotage your whole act should be able to go up there and talk about
weird Hawaiian shit or like anything,
you know?
Cause he's funny enough and I,
that's me being a weird guy,
like trying to push him and he's like,
please don't do that.
And I'm like,
I'm not going to do that.
You asshole.
So I go up and he's just like,
can you do it?
Can you do 10 minutes?
I'm like,
dude,
I did two hours at UCLA without fucking any notes or anything like this.
And they had to kick me off the stage.
I could have gone for hours.
And I hear those like Chapelle and those guys do like the 14 hour legs are never
good.
Yeah.
So I go up there and I,
and it's me and I did it like a smothers brothers comedy routine with his
brother.
Like we just riffed off each other and all the weird shit that happened just on
the flight to Hawaii.
And so we're just killing and he's on the side of the stage and he's like,
it was like a movie.
It's like kid him off the stage.
They are fucking killing.
I don't want to follow that.
And I was like,
yes.
He didn't want to follow you and want to follow us.
If you're listening right now,
Bobby fucking motherfucker.
Wow.
Fucking killed your ass.
You Little Bitch Bob.
No Bobby's but Bobby killed after us.
He's the fucking,
I love him.
It's,
he's,
he's just fucking,
that's what I'm talking about.
He goes for it and you know,
yeah.
Bobby Lee's the real deal.
He's really crazy.
The first time I met Bobby,
I'm at Bobby.
Fuck.
It was like the nineties and Bobby and it was in San Diego and he wasn't on mad
TV,
wasn't doing anything back then.
He was just doing stand up at the comedy store in La Jolla.
Yeah.
This is probably like shit 95 or [inaudible] 96 maybe,
I dunno.
Long time ago.
Right.
And it was with a bunch of comics,
went to a strip club and she's Mexican Gang Bangers to the Strip club and one of
them had long hair and tattoos on his face.
It was the 90s you had tattooed tears on his face and he had eyes like he had
these eyes,
you'd looked in them.
You knew this motherfucker had seen some shit.
I don't know if he'd kill people.
Right.
I don't know.
I don't know what I mean.
I'm just guessing.
But if I had a guest,
fuck yeah,
he's killed people.
Right.
And Bobby somehow or another insulted him by talking to his girl,
like there was a girl that like,
maybe it was his girlfriend who was a dancer there.
And Bobby talked to the girl and the guy stood up and Bobby was like,
fuck these bitches.
They don't know shit.
Right.
You know,
like,
and,
and I was like,
you're going to get me killed.
I go,
we're leaving right now.
You come in with me or I'm fucking leaving you here and me and I think it was
Jimmy Schubert with myth.
We ran outside and jumped in my car at a toilet,
a supra,
right.
We jumped in my fucking car and Bobby like barely made it in time to get into
the back seat and we took off.
I'm like,
we're going to get shot,
right?
Like I know the look of people that will shoot you.
Right.
And that guy will fucking shoot you.
Right?
I'm pretty sure.
But he,
in a similar way,
he has that,
this weird Korean energy and like,
uh,
like a real artist,
like a real self.
Like he says,
destructive,
complete,
super self destructive.
Told some stories on a podcast about going down to Mexico on the,
in the middle of Filming Mad TV.
He would leave the set,
go down to Mexico,
do drugs.
It was carrying a fucking kitchen knife,
get hookers come back gacked out of his fucking mind,
holding onto the knife.
Just completely wired to the gills like at Mad TV globally.
The giant knife on him.
He's just so fucking great.
But yeah,
the same kind of like the,
the rebellion against this ultra suppressive childhood for sure.
But to David Cho,
don't ever get rid of that.
Suck my fart song.
Alright,
we gotta get Outta here.
This,
this,
this contest DVD,
asa.com Joe.
That's where I'll thank you man.
Thank you.
Oh,
always a good time,
my brother.
I'm glad we got to talk about this in a way and talk about your,
the controversy in a way where people,
I think they'll understand you now better.
Well look,
I,
I like going on stern.
I like going on your show.
I like,
I like talk like it's Sorta hard to talk to people that don't like,
they're like,
shut the fuck up.
Right.
You know,
then it's like,
I know you,
I know you would understand.
You know,
and like,
thank you for calling me.
And that meant a lot to me and yeah,
I appreciate it.
DVD [inaudible] dot com it's back.
It's back.
This is about 70 episodes broad broadcasting from an insane asylum.
This book no one wanted to put out,
that's pretty much almost sold out.
There's,
if you want to get it to David,
show.com and this money I'm giving it,
the contest ends on Halloween,
but I'm going to give it away on a,
on November 2nd during our whole fuck fest during that thing and a,
yeah.
Listen,
man,
I hope you kicked diabetes.
I hope you get healthy,
but don't change.
Don't change.
Fuck the haters.
David Choe,
ladies and gentlemen tonight,
everybody.
Big Kiss.
Thank you.
That was fun.